Ich bin der Beste, der dich hier hat. Ich bin der Beste, der dich hier hat.
Ich bin der Beste, der dich hier hat.
Ich bin der Beste, der dich hier hat. Ich bin der Beste, der dich hier hat. Sicherlich wird es vielleicht unter Umständen auch noch ein kleineres Gerät geben, was Videos abspielt, aber du willst natürlich bei Videos auch eine gewisse Mindestgröße haben. Und derzeit, also jetzt wird ja erst mal diskutiert, ob denn die Bildschirmgröße von dem iPod ausreicht. Das wird sich dann zeigen. Die Qualität soll wohl ganz gut sein. Ich habe auch noch keine Hand gehabt, habe es aber schon einbestellt.
Was hast du bestellt? Nano?
Da musste ich einfach die Kauftaste drücken.
Ja, ich war auch knapp davor, aber 400 Kröten.
Augen zu und durch, aber nein, also der Nano wird es nicht können.
Habe ich meiner Bank auch gesagt.
Aber du kannst... Sei doch mal ruhig. Also man kann, Podcasting Support hat er, aber eben nur für Audio. Wobei das mit dem Nur-Audio ist natürlich auch so eine Sache. Der iPod kann ja nicht nur MP3 abspielen, sondern auch MPEG-4, AAC-Audiodateien, die auch noch das spezielle Feature haben, dass man da so Standbilder mit einbauen kann. Also so wie Slides sozusagen. Das heißt, während man hört, wird dann immer an bestimmten Stellen ein neues Bild eingeblendet. Das wird auch von einigen Podcastern benutzt. Zum Beispiel gibt es wieder von Adam Curry diesen Podfinder-Podcast, wo er immer regelmäßig neue Podcasts vorstellt. Und dann wird halt auch immer entsprechende Icon mit eingeblendet. Wenn man das dann in seinem iTunes abhört, dann kann man auch gleich draufklicken. Das ist auf der passenden Webseite. Also das ist dann schon alles so ein bisschen Hypertext-Multimedia-Klimpe. Soweit ich weiß, wird dann halt auch auf dem Nano das angezeigt. Aber das ist dann auch der ganze Spaß, den man hat.
Zum Thema Nanotechnik, Bookmarks, iPods und so weiter ist es ja immer ganz nett, mit diesen, sag ich mal, längeren Files, die man bekommt. Der Nano ist ja oder die iPods sind ja genial, sag ich mal, für Hörbücher. Da gibt es ja dieses berühmte M4B-Format. Aber irgendwie habe ich dann noch nicht immer was gefunden, wie man selber irgendwie Bookmarks setzen kann. Also sprich, man ist in irgendeinem Stream drinnen und sagt, okay, man drückt jetzt mal Vortaste und man kommt dann zu der nächsten Endung. Gibt es da von euch irgendwo Informationen noch, oder ich habe da nichts gefunden? Wahrscheinlich sind die ganzen iPod-Benutzer, Apple-Benutzern, die sagen, okay, ich nehme es halt so und es ist gut.
Wie du selbst in einem Audiobuch sozusagen einzelne Stellen setzen kannst?
Genau, kann ich einfach sagen, so zack.
Nee, kannst du nicht, dass das das Problem ist, dass der Markt so danach schreit, dass das Zeug wirklich, also den Eindruck habe ich, weil ich habe mich jetzt ein paar Mal schon über den Kauf von Audiobooks richtig geärgert, weil wenn du einen 3-Stunden Audiobook hast, in dem Fall... Ja, wurscht. Und dann brennst du davon mehrere CDs so und dann kannst du da nicht mal durchskippen bzw. du hörst irgendwie eine Stunde lang auf einer Fahrt oder so und willst denn da weiterhören? Geht nicht. Und das Zeug wird einfach so schnell auf den Markt gedonnert, dass das ist ähnlich wie bei DVDs, weißt du? Du kaufst eine DVD und da ist da so ein Zettelchen drin, so ein dünnes. Ohne extra Features und keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, wenn ich deine Frage jetzt richtig verstanden habe, du möchtest halt, während du, während du hörst, ein Bookmark setzen?
Nicht, nicht wenn ich höre ein Bookmark setzen, sondern ich sag mal, du kriegst die meisten Audiobooks, kriegt man über, ich sag mal, die einstiegenden Quellen wie iTunes oder auch andere Quellen, kriegst du halt, sag ich mal, als mp3. Na ja, iTunes nicht mp3, aber du kriegst, wie ich sag mal, viele Sachen als mp3. So, packst du dir irgendwie ein großes Pfeiler zusammen, oder rippst dir selber, ich hab selber Harry Potter 5, ne, ne Quatsch, ne 6, das war der Schwarm, ne, der heißt halt, aber hier, jedenfalls du hast einen Haufen CDs, rippst dir die Sachen runter und dann hast du irgendwie 100.000 mp3-Falls. Die kannst du natürlich, sag ich mal, in deinen iTunes reinziehen und, hm, toll, skippen und hin und her springen.
Na was möchtest du denn dann tun?
Na ich möchte einfach so ein großes Hörbuch haben und sagen, okay, ich möchte jetzt, sag ich mal, von Kapitel zu Kapitel springen.
Okay, ja, gibt's zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder du machst halt pro Kapitel eine Datei, dann hast du das quasi automatisch. Und soweit ich weiß, wenn du die MP3-Datei dem richtigen Genre zuordnest, diesem Hörbuch, dann kannst du halt auf dem iPod auch diese Hörbuch-Speed-Features mit schneller und langsamer haben, bin mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz sicher. Klappt nicht? Okay, wie auch immer, auf dem Fall gibt es ein Tool, dessen Namen kann ich nochmal rausfummeln, mit dem man sich halt selber MPEG-4 AAC-Dateien machen kann, die diese Bookmarks unterstützen. Da kannst du auch noch Bilder reinschmeißen.
Naja, da hast du nur die Bookmarks, die praktisch die letzte Position merken haben.
Nein, nein.
Das führt uns ja jetzt ein bisschen weg.
Fühlt uns nicht vollkratz an. Ja, ja, also mit Podcasting hat das nun wirklich gar nichts auf sich.
Das hat schon auch was mit Podcasting zu tun.
Bei Podcast ist es genau das gleiche Problem.
Stimmt, wenn die Datei lang genug ist.
Ja, nee, es gibt durchaus auch vorindizierte... Ich meine, ich würde das auch gerne mit Chaosradio machen. Das ist natürlich ein gewisser Produktionsaufwand. Die Zeit haben wir leider nicht. Aber wenn man Thema 1, Thema 2, Thema 3 hat, man weiß, da und da ist das und das passiert. Warum nicht nachher einfach da einen Bookmark setzen und das Indy-Datei auch selber mit reinbauen?
Das geht auch bei den AAC-Files, ne?
Also kann ich vollkommen verstehen. Und wie gesagt, es gibt einen Tunemessage. Gerade der Name entfallen. Aber ich forschte mal nach. Vielleicht hat der Chat ja auch eine Antwort. Okay, Frage beantwortet.
Frage beantwortet, wenn es da einen Tunemessage gibt, ist ganz nett. Ich habe es noch nicht gefunden, aber es sei mal ein großes Problem, weil ansonsten ist die Kiste halt doch ziemlich nett, der iPod.
Jo, ziemlich teuer, ziemlich nett. Andreas, danke für deinen Anruf.
Bitte, bitte.
Und gute Nacht.
So, jetzt Thomas.
Jetzt aber, jetzt Thomas.
Jetzt haben wir nämlich einen der bekanntesten Podcaster in diesem Land am Telefon. Er weilt zurzeit in München, wenn das richtig ist.
Ja.
Und heißt Thomas Warnhoff. Hallo Thomas.
Hallo, grüße euch.
Kannst du uns hören in Bayern?
Ja, wahnsinn, super schön.
Ja, das ist jetzt hockig.
Du bist gar nicht zu Hause, du hast unseren Stream wahrscheinlich nicht gehört, die Sendung bisher.
Ich habe die letzten fünf Minuten gehört und habe gerade auf meinem Nano festgestellt, dass mein John Grisham die Schuldhörbuch von Audible chapter hat. Ja, wenn es...
Ja, und ich glaube Audible steht da auch für Qualität, sage ich jetzt einfach mal so. Also ich weiß, dass viele Sachen von denen wirklich gut gemacht sind, aber auch nicht alle. Gut, aber das hat uns gerade aus so ein bisschen, wir haben jetzt seit einer Stunde...
Audible ist genau was?
Das ist ein Hörbuchvertrieb, Verlag.
Audible.de, ja die machen so Hörbücher da.
So Thomas, jetzt müssen wir aber erstmal ein bisschen erzählen, wer du bist, beziehungsweise was du so machst. Was vielleicht vielen Leuten sagt, ist die Warnhofs Wunderbare Welt der Wissenschaft. Das ist eine Podcastserie, die du machst, die auch schon ausgezeichnet wurde, richtig? Ach so, wie bei den frühen eigenen Websites.
Wie bei Paul Kirchhoff, der war doch auch Reformer des Jahres, ausgezeichnet von der Nummer, von dem Verein, der ihn sowieso bezahlt.
Vielleicht ist das die Namensendung hinten. Wir hoffen, dass da keine Parallelen bestehen.
Wir sollten auch mehr Awards verleihen hier in der Sendung.
Das ist immer eine gute Idee.
Wir verleihen dir jetzt den Fritz Podcast Award.
Super.
Egal.
Gerne.
Ich bin glücklich und ohne meine Eltern wäre das nicht möglich gewesen.
Dankst du zufällig auch den Mitgliedern der Akademie?
Ich danke den Mitgliedern der Akademie und den Jurauren und hoffe aber, dass das nicht der Grund ist, dass mein Podcast jetzt illegal in Tauschbörsen erscheint.
Auweia, das wäre furchtbar.
Das ist natürlich auch das Schöne an Podcasts, solange sie kostenlos sind, braucht man da keine Angst haben. Das ist aber nur nebenbei. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr beliebter Podcast. Wir haben auch eine der kürzeren Ausgaben von dir hier, aber auch die dauert eine Viertelstunde. Wenn wir die jetzt spielen, dann wissen Hörer, die gerade dazuschalten, überhaupt nicht mehr, wo sie sind, aber wir können da wenigstens mal reinhören, auf alle Fälle gleich. Du machst aber noch ganz viele andere Sachen. Vielleicht gibst du selber mal ein bisschen Überblick. Das Stichwort, zu dem wir natürlich auch kommen wollen, ist der Podcastverband.
Ein Überblick über die Podcastszene, richtig?
Es ist nicht ausschließlich ein Überblick. Wir wollen machen, wir nennen es das Audiomagazin für deinen MP3-Player. Das sind Podcasts, die wir vorstellen. Wir reden ein bisschen über andere Podcasts. Wir geben aber auch Reisetipps. Wir geben Musiktipps. Wir zeigen, was international so ein Podcasting los ist. Und haben jetzt auch schon Videocasts gemacht. Der erste ist draußen und die nächsten sind in Planung.
Unter welcher Adresse findet das statt?
Den Link gibt es über die Podcastshow.de. Der Feed für den Videocast ist etwas komplizierter. podcastshowvcast.blogspot.com podcastshowvcast.blogspot.com podcastshowvcast.blogspot.com Ach, das kann man ja auf der Seite alles finden. Aber das gibt es alles auf der Seite, genau.
Podcastshow.
Das ist auch wieder so ein Effekt, den es ja immer geben muss. Das einzelne Leute Inhalte herstellen. Und dann muss irgendwann jemand kommen, der ein bisschen vorsortiert und sagt...
Vorsortiert, bewertet, ja.
Das ist ein Metablogger.
Ja, wir wollen es vor allem sehr subjektiv bewerten. Wir halten nicht wirklich was von diesen Datenbank-optimierten Ranking-Systemen. Weil das irgendwie albern ist. Wir haben gesagt, wir hören einfach in Sachen rein und bringen auch mal wieder Alte und bringen Neue und wollen da ein bisschen... Denen, die sich mit Podcasting nicht auskennen, sagen, hey, hör da mal rein, was es für tolle Sachen gibt. Das ist so der Ziel bei der ganzen Geschichte. Und wir wollen da eine Menge Spaß haben und haben den auch. Wir haben ein Studio, mit dem wir das zusammen machen können, die da auch sehr engagiert sind und da können wir viel Unsinn treiben.
Sag mal Thomas, jetzt gibst du einmal in der Woche, glaube ich, die wunderbare Welt der Wissenschaft heraus.
Ja.
Machst du diesen ganzen anderen Kram noch? Wie viel Zeit kostet dich die Podcasterei pro Tag, pro Woche?
Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist weniger als ich denke. Also viele sagen immer, wie machst du das alles? Aber eine Viertelstunde Show produziere ich am Stück. Das ist dann also eine Viertelstunde plus vielleicht nochmal eine Viertelstunde Technik oder eine halbe Stunde auch. Das ist gar nicht so dramatisch.
Die Recherche dafür läuft nebenbei, weil du sowieso Wissenschaftszeitungen liest oder?
Die läuft nebenbei, über RSS sieht. Das kriege ich ganz viel mit und Nachrichtensendungen.
Dann ist das doch aber ein bisschen in die Tasche gelogen, oder? Also wenn du sagst, sag mal eine Stunde aufnehmen und schneiden. Und schneidest du überhaupt?
Ja, bis ein muss ich schon mal schneiden.
Ab und zu ja.
Rausschneiden?
Oder reinschneiden?
Dann musst du das Zeug ja auch auf den Server kriegen, der steht ja auch nicht direkt neben dir, nehme ich an.
Ja, aber ich bin multitaskingfähig. Also ich mach das wirklich so. Wenn das Ding eine Viertelstunde hoch lädt, dann kann ich in der Viertelstunde schon mal das Bügeleisen anschmeißen und die ersten zwei Hemden bügeln oder sowas.
Naja, ich sitze ja auch nicht vor einem Wartebalken, aber podcast iron sozusagen.
Nee, aber podcast iron. Aber wenn du sagst, das dauert etwa eine Stunde, aber die Recherche für das, was du da erzählst und so, die musst du ja auch mit einberechnen.
Ja, die verteile ich über die Woche. Also ich schreibe mir da keine Stundenzettel oder sowas auf. Klar dauert sowas Zeit. Aber wenn ich Briefmarkensammler bin, dann dauert es auch Zeit. Und wenn ich bei der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr bin, dann muss ich auch immer zu den Übungen. Also wenn man ein Hobby ernsthaft macht, dann nimmt man sich die Zeit dafür.
Das erinnert mich jetzt aber doch. Auf einmal mehr Stunden.
Siehst du das so, als Hobby, für das man sich Zeit nimmt?
Auf jeden Fall. Also ich glaube, alles, was man so ehrenamtlich oder privat macht und was jetzt nicht gleich mit Geld verbunden ist, ist doch irgendeine Form von Hobby, die man macht.
Ob ich jetzt Weblogs schreibe oder... Nicht gleich mit Geld verbunden bedeutet, dass du schon hoffst, davon irgendwann auch mal deinen Lebensunterhalt finanzieren zu können?
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich der Johnny Häusler der Podcastszene werden kann, aber...
Du siehst, ich verdiene ja auch kein Geld damit.
Aber warte mal, das geht ab, du. Mit anderen Sachen, also grundsätzlich kann man da vielleicht irgendwann mal Geld verdienen, aber keiner weiß so richtig wie.
Äh, doch. Aber ich sag's nicht, ich sag's nicht.
Ja gut, ich...
Trotzdem gibt es da schon eine ganze Menge Interessenwahrung in der Szene. Ihr habt diesen Podcastverband gegründet. Kannst du vielleicht noch mal kurz sagen, was der Grund dafür war, den zu gründen und womit sich der Verband beschäftigt?
Also der Sinn des Verbandes ist so, die Interessen dieser privaten, unabhängigen, nicht-kommerziellen Podcaster ein bisschen nach außen hin zu wahren. Weil es ja eine ganze Menge jetzt Zeitungen und Radiosender gibt und Fernsehsender, die machen jetzt alle Podcasting. Und da haben wir so ein bisschen die Befürchtung gehabt, dass wir da vielleicht untergehen. Und deswegen wollen wir eine laute Stimme nach draußen sein, um zu zeigen, wie vielfältig dieser ganze Podcastbereich ist und was es für tolle Sachen gibt. Und dass es Radio für jedermann ist. Das heißt, jedermann kann es machen und jedermann kann es hören. Und das wollen wir so ein bisschen transportieren, einfach so als Lobby für das Podcasting an und für sich. Und intern wollen wir so ein bisschen den Podcastern, die vielleicht Hilfe brauchen, diese Hilfe auch geben. Sei es bei rechtlichen Sachen, bei technischen Sachen, bei organisatorischen Dingen. Wir haben jetzt so einen Themen-Tag gemacht, das hat Daniel Peters organisiert. Und wir haben als Verband einfach so ein bisschen Hilfestellung gegeben bei Pressearbeit und solchen Dingen.
Das ist das Verband.
Genau, ihr habt da auch die passende Webseite dazu, podcastverband.de, oder? Oder ist das podstar.de? Bring mich mal...
Nein, podcastverband.de.
Genau. Und mit podstar.de, was hat es damit auf sich?
podstar.de ist erstmal ein Podcasting-Portal. Den kennen wir natürlich. Wir haben nicht direkt was mit dir. Der hat bei diesem Themen-Tag das Hosting für die ganzen Files gemacht. Was sehr, sehr lieb von ihm war.
Okay, der prang gerade ein Foto von dir direkt auf der Hauptseite. Deswegen war ich gerade etwas verwirrt.
Gut.
Ja, ihr wollt die Interessen warnen. Was sind denn diese Interessen? Was muss da gewahrt werden? Was ist denn da angefangen?
Wo ist denn da ein Foto von... Ich hab ein anderes Foto.
Was soll gewahrt werden? Ja, Interessen heißt, zu zeigen, wie vielfältig diese ganze Podcastgeschichte sein kann. Zu zeigen, dass sie unabhängig ist. Dass es nicht dieses MB3-Schnitzel von irgendeinem Radiosender ist, den er jetzt ins Netz stellt, sondern dass da Leute sind, die ganz engagiert, bisweilen sogar journalistische Formate machen oder unterhaltende Formate. Dass es ganz, ganz tolle Musik in dieser Podcastwelt gibt, von der der normale Radiohörer ja noch nie was hören durfte oder konnte.
Wie glaubst du denn oder glaubst du, dass es überhaupt nötig ist? Ich finde ja, das Problem ist, wenn ich das meistens alles so höre, also nicht die Podcasts selbst, sondern wenn darüber geredet wird, dann denke ich, offener Kanal. Und das schreckt mich ab.
Ja, wobei es auch im offenen Kanal, in den 24 Stunden, die die machen, gibt es immer in 15 Minuten eine Perle, jeden Tag.
Ist das so?
Das ist so. Das ist das Problem, du verlierst den Überblick. Du kannst ja nicht den ganzen Tag offenen Kanal hören, da wirst du wahnsinnig. Nur für die 15 Minuten.
Ach, ich glaube, da findet jeder schon irgendwo seine Sachen. Ich finde ja auch im Radio irgendwann meinen Sender oder meine Sendung. Das Problem ist nur beim Radio immer, dass ich dann auch am Radio sitzen muss. Und die Zeit habe ich ja nicht. Und dafür gibt es dann tolle Podcasts. Es gibt ja genug Verzeichnisse, die das auch wirklich inhaltlich mal ein bisschen gliedern. Also sagen, das ist Wissenschaft, das ist Sport, das ist Musik. Und da findet man sich doch dann irgendwann zurecht. Das war am Anfang so, dass jeder mal überall reingehört hat. Aber ich glaube, mittlerweile wissen die Leute, dass es verschiedene Genres gibt und holen sich dann ihre Interessensgebiete. Also ich glaube, wir sind schon viel weiter als Bürgerfunk und offener Kanal auf jeden Fall.
Vielleicht haben auch alle geübt im Bürgerfunk und im offenen Kanal. Vielleicht ist jetzt allen klar, man muss schon auch ein bisschen unterhalten, damit die Leute dran bleiben oder so. Vielleicht gibt es vielleicht ist da einfach jetzt ein bisschen Erfahrung mit.
Ja, es schließt sich ja auch alles nicht aus. Also es gibt zum Beispiel auch diese Verband, weiß ich jetzt nicht, die Vereinigung der Freien Radios in Deutschland. Freie radios.net, freie strichradios.net, die auch jetzt Podcasting anbieten. Das hängt noch so ein bisschen von der Zuspielung der einzelnen Radios auch ab. Aber da kann man sich eben diese ganze alternative Berichterstattung eben jetzt auch bequem als Podcasting machen. Ich sehe ja auch Podcasting zunächst einmal als Technik, die jetzt erstmal alles möglich macht. Und ich denke, was die kulturelle Konsequenz aus all dem ist, das können wir jetzt bestenfalls erahnen.
Genau, ich glaube, wir werden auch im nächsten Jahr erstmal sehen, was da noch passiert, auch im Bereich Videocasting. Da würden, glaube ich, auch ganz witzige Sachen passieren. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, so was journalistische Formate angeht, so kleine dreiminütige Zuspiele als eine Ergänzung zu einem Podcast. Das ist übrigens ganz witzig, irgendwie scheinen die Videocaster einfach von den Podcastern vereinnahmt zu werden. Aber das fängt schon an, dass die Videocaster bei iTunes und der Podcast gelistet werden.
Ist mir so aufgefallen. Na ja, ich sehe da auch...
Und die fallen dann mit einem Videoverzeichnis rein auf dem Rechner, aber ansonsten...
Ich sehe da nicht so den großen Unterschied, muss ich sagen, weil auch die Videocaster casten mal Audio und haben auch mal einen PDF in ihrem Feed. Und genauso haben jetzt die Audio-Podcaster auch ab und zu mal ein kleines Videoschnipselchen drin. Also das misst sich schon. Von daher finde ich das schon ganz okay, dass man das erstmal alles unter dem Podcasting-Überbegriff macht, weil Videocasting kann sich jetzt so recht auch keiner was drunter vorstellen. Und wenn man sich die Szene anschaut, sind da derzeit noch eine ganze Menge Begriffe im Rollen. Also Witcasting, Vodcasting, V-Casting, Vlogging. Das ist absurd und ich glaube auch, dass das Videopodcasting sich da durchsetzen wird. Aber das ist jetzt nur mein Eindruck zur aktuellen Situation.
Ich finde es gut, dass sich das mischt. Also ich finde das sehr befruchtend für alle.
Ich denke auch, das ist richtig mal Multimedia.
Das ist wahrscheinlich zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte des Multimedia.
Jetzt wird es wirklich Multimedial. Und Podcasting erlaubt halt einfach maximale Freiheit, sowohl beim Sender als auch beim Empfänger. Und das ist eben neu.
Thomas, du beschäftigst dich ja auf verschiedensten Ebenen doch ein bisschen intensiver mit dem ganzen Thema. Als ich es z.B. tue, der halt einfach nur täglich seinen Kram da macht. Und ansonsten, ich muss zugeben und ich hoffe, da kriege ich jetzt keinen Bashing für. Ich höre extrem wenig Podcasts. Weil ich die Zeit nicht dafür habe.
Du wirst ja auch keine Weblogs.
In den letzten zwei Wochen tatsächlich extrem wenig, aber sonst sehr viel. Und da liegt halt meiner Meinung nach auch der Vorteil. Ich kann halt einen Text schneller scannen. Also ich kann schneller drüber gehen, gucken, interessiert er mich und dann lese ich ihn. Beim Podcast weiß ich einfach nicht, was kommt. Und dann nützt es auch nicht irgendwie mal schnell durchscrollen oder so, weil dann kriege ich nichts mit. Ich muss den hören. Ich muss mich darauf konzentrieren. Ich muss mir die Viertelstunde, die halbe Stunde nehmen.
Oder einen Podcaster haben, der in der Lage ist, tatsächlich fürs Hören auch seine Dinge zur Verfügung zu stellen. Weil vieles, was ich höre, ist einfach lyrisch abgelesen oder lyrisch gesprochen. Und wirklich nicht beachtet, dass man nichts zurückblättern kann.
Ich werde einfach mal ein bisschen in Podcastshow.de reinhören.
Aber ich wollte eigentlich eine Frage stellen.
Entschuldigung.
Hier habe ich nur ein Intro. Welche war es denn? Genau, da helft ihr natürlich mit der Podcastshow. Habe ich aber gerade schon erwähnt, wie eine eigentliche Frage war, was dieses Gerät angeht. Also der Name, der sich ja auf den iPod bezieht, wo wir aber immer wieder betonen, dass es natürlich nicht um dieses Gerät von Apple geht.
Na, aber er sieht schon gut aus.
Jaha, kriegst du einen umsonst, oder was?
Leider, obwohl, ich könnte mir nicht das öfter sagen, vielleicht.
Das ist Johnnys Gewinnspiel.
Genau.
Das wäre schick, oder, ein paar iPods verlosen?
Es heißt ja auch nicht iPodcasting. Die kleine Nussschale, die man halt mit sich rumträgt, das ist schon gar kein schlechtes Bild dafür.
Thomas, hören die Leute das Zeug auf dem tragbaren MP3-Player, oder hören sie es am Rechner?
Sowohl als auch. Also ich bin mir da noch nicht wirklich sicher, weil ich hab auch durchaus eine nennenswerte Zahl von Downloads über diesen Flash-Player bei mir auf der Seite. Und ich weiß, dass Adam Curry irgendwann mal völlig fertig war, also irgendwie einen Link auf der Seite vergessen hatte zum Download. Und die Leute ihn angemacht haben, sie würden das doch da am Computer hören. Und er hat gedacht, das darf nicht wahr sein, ich erfinde das automatische Abonnieren, und ihr geht auf meine Seite und macht einen ganz normalen File-Download.
Ich sag euch, wir irren uns alle, was diese Technik angeht. Ich weiß, sobald man an RSS irgendetwas rüttelt, und ich finde RSS auch ganz großartig, aber solange es nicht im Browser drin ist und so, vergesst das, dass die Leute, also die Leute, es ist in einigen Browsern, aber vergesst das, dass die Leute sich weiter noch mal damit auseinandersetzen oder auch noch ein zusätzliches Programm installieren. Das muss so integriert sein, dass ich nicht mal weiß. Und ich glaube, der wahre Erfolg von RSS liegt in der Syndication zwischen Websites, also intern sozusagen im Hintergrund. Da liegen die großen Chancen von RSS, aber nicht in der Auslieferung zu den einzelnen Leuten, weil kein Mensch an einem Windows-Rechner, der im Büro sitzt, wird sich einen RSS-Client installieren.
Brauche ich auch nicht wirklich, aber ich gebe dir recht, das ist ja das Schöne bei iTunes. Bei iTunes sehe ich nichts von RSS, sondern da sage ich, will ich haben. Und das ist in der Tat genau die Geschichte, wie es laufen soll. Und deswegen tun wir uns das schwer, weil diese ganze Podcast-Berichterstattung auch so sehr in der Technik-Ecke angefangen hat. Und das will keiner. Und deswegen kam der Bum erst mit iTunes, wo die Leute geklickt haben und da war es.
Aber auch, muss man auch anmerken, ein kleines Problem, wer sich dann tatsächlich mit der Erstellung der RSS-Feeds ein bisschen beschäftigt und das, was du bestätigen können, Thomas, iTunes zum Beispiel, sagt dann einfach, da gibt es jetzt ein paar extra Tags für die XML-Datei. Das heißt, da fügen wir ein paar extra iTunes-Tags ein. Also, wenn ich meinen RSS-Feeds zum Beispiel bei iTunes mir angucke, da ist kein Bildchen drin, da gibt es bestimmte Features, die dir iTunes Store anbietet. Das heißt, ich muss meine Datei extra für iTunes bearbeiten. Jetzt lass uns mal vorstellen, da kommen noch zwei, drei Leute, die alle ihre extra Wünsche haben und die diese Feeds quasi nicht mehr nach Standard bearbeiten, sondern sagen, wenn du hier...
Ich muss dir da, also ich sehe da überhaupt kein Problem.
Das ist ja ein großes Problem.
Nee, das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen technischer werden, aber es ist insofern überhaupt gar kein Problem, als das erstens, das was iTunes da eingebaut hat, das fehlt halt dem RSS auch wirklich. Also so was wie vorher mal die Dateigröße angeben und so und klar zwischen Beschreibungen und Untertiteln unterscheiden, ist einfach nicht spezifiziert in diesem RSS 2.0, was sowieso ein bisschen unterspezifiziert ist. Und dazu kommt, dass Apple schon korrekt einfach in eigenen, wie man das nennt, einen XML-Namespace gemacht hat. Also das ist separiert, das schmeißt man halt zusätzlich noch mit rein, damit iTunes das richtig macht. Aber es stört keinen anderen RSS-Rider. Also es ist kein wirkliches Problem, zumal man solche Feats auch generieren kann mit Tools. Ich hab mir das hier auch schon mal so ein bisschen zusammengeklickt. Das ist alles sehr elegant. Das ist echt kein großes Problem. Also da sehe ich jetzt keine Gefahr.
Ich finde alles, was da technisch ist, ist ein großes Problem. Sowohl für die Hörer als auch für die Leute, die es machen sollen.
Ihr müsst einfach nur das tolle Loudblock-Content-Management-System haben. Das macht alles selber.
Ja, aber die WordPress-Integration...
Das ist aber trotzdem toll.
Das ist aber ein schönes Beispiel. Ja, genau. Loudblock, das kann man ruhig mal erwähnen. Das ist so eine Software. Von wem waren die noch gleich? Der auch, glaube ich, einen Blog unter prignanz.de, richtig? Und ja, das ist eine PRP-Software. Eine einfache wäre, also Lust hat, sich mal eben so eine webbasierte Podcasting-Plattform aufzusetzen. Der kann das damit relativ leicht machen. Also wenn man Zugriff auf einen eigenen Server hat, natürlich. Ich habe es selber noch nicht gemacht, aber gerade kurz vor der Sendung hat mir jemand noch mal kurz beschrieben, dass er das mal eben ausprobiert hätte und in 10 Minuten war das fertig. Ja, das geht sehr gut. Also das ist schon sehr schön und solche Lösungen werden wir jetzt eine ganze Menge finden. Also ich sehe ehrlich gesagt, die Technologien, die hier vor allem zum Einsatz kommen, die sind alle extrem simpel. Also von der Technologie-Seite her betrachtet. Das sind eigentlich relativ einfache Sachen. Dass das nicht jeder versteht, ist ja klar, aber das muss auch nicht jeder verstehen. Die Leute, die dir das produzieren, für die ist es auf jeden Fall sehr leicht erlernbar. Deswegen wird das auch noch der Bogen noch zu nehmen.
Aber ich will das doch nicht lernen. Wenn ich was mitzuteilen habe, dann will ich das mitteilen und ich vorher lernen, wie ich das mitteile.
Ja, aber wenn du Radio machst und hier in deinen Reglern da drehst, dann musst du halt auch erstmal was lernen.
Aber ich habe aber immer noch das Problem, ich habe keinen eigenen Web-Space, also bei mir läuft kein Server, ich habe kein, wie heißt es hier, WordPress oder sowas, sondern ich benutze zum Bloggen Today. Ja, wie mache ich es dann da?
Ja, das wird nicht mehr lange dauern und du wirst auch Today einen großen Button haben, wo drauf steht, hier mein eigenes Audioblog, mein eigener Podcast, also das ist doch nur eine Frage der Zeit, also das wird nicht mehr lange dauern.
Das ist eine Frage von Traffic vor allem, weil es sind ja mächtig große da rein.
Ja, und ich weigere mich immer noch zu bezahlen.
Oh, wie ist denn das bei dir? Hast du da Probleme mit dem Traffic?
Nein, ich nicht, also es gibt da, was ich eben schon erwähnt hatte, dieses Podster, das ist ein Host, bei dem auch ich meine Files habe. Also ich habe noch irgendwo in Amiland einen Server stehen, der ist auch traffic-free, mit entsprechend grottigem Service, aber wenn es denn mal Notarmann ist, kann ich da auch noch Sachen hinlegen. Aber es ist schon ein Problem. Also gerade bei meiner Sendung, der Michael Elstörfer von Podster, der hat dann als iTunes geboomt ist, schon mal gesagt, holla, holla, da rauchen jetzt ganz schön die Datenleitungen. Weil das sind, wenn ich 30 Minuten mache, sind das vielleicht mal so 30 Megabyte und wenn davon mal 4000 runtergeladen werden, dann ist da schon ein bisschen was.
Übrigens zum Thema Traffic, die 23 Downloads von einem Video gerade, das war ich. Ich habe da immer drauf geklickt und habe nichts gesehen und dachte, das geht nicht und habe immer wieder drauf geklickt und im Hintergrund war dann das Fenster mit den...
Die müsst ihr dann wieder raus.
Ja, die müsst ihr rausziehen.
Ja, also es gibt diese Probleme, aber diese Probleme sind alle ganz gut lösbar. Mir fällt da gerade ein Beispiel ein, auch wenn sich das jetzt mehr auf Videoblogging bezieht. Aber das will ich hier gleich mal nennen, bevor ich es wieder vergesse. Unter freevlog.org gibt es ein Online-Tutorial, wie man sein eigenes Videoblog an den Start bringt. Das geht am letzten Endes genauso für Audio. Unter zu Hilfenamen von solchen Servern wie archive.org, die das Hosting von freiem Content einfach unterstützen. Aber ewig.
Ja, aber Our Media und Archive, das ist schon echt. Also hast du mal versucht, da was hochzuspielen?
Ja, das geht. Also man sollte sich so ein, also ein, zwei Tage, Delay kann es schon mal sein, bis es veröffentlicht ist. Bei archive.org, bei Our Media geht es eigentlich recht flott.
Ich hatte, gut, war allerdings auch sehr in der Anfangszeit von Our Media. Da hatte ich genau das gleiche Problem wie bei archive.org.
Kostenlos ist kostenlos. Aber man kriegt auch für 50 Euro im Monat heutzutage Routeserver, wo man irgendwie Terabyte-Traffic hat. Also das ist alles nicht mehr das große Problem. Allerdings gibt es schon auch Seiten, die unter ihrem Erfolg leiden. Vor ein, zwei Monaten ist zum Beispiel das Nerd-TV von dem Robert Princhley rausgekommen, wo er immer so Interviews macht mit Persönlichkeiten der Computertechnologie-Szene. Das war natürlich alles hochbeliebt. Und die haben auch einen Podcast. Das heißt, als Audio kriegt man das als Podcast. Aber eigentlich sind das auch Videoaufzeichnungen. Und ich habe denen auch mal eine Mail geschrieben, ja, wie ist denn hier Video? Podcast wäre doch mal ganz angemessen. Natürlich hätten sie ja schon drüber nachgedacht. Das Problem ist nur, dass sie dermaßen viel Traffic sehen, dass sie da ein richtiges Problem haben. Weil viele Leute das dann auch abonnieren würden, ohne sich das wirklich anzuschauen. Und unter den derzeitigen Bedingungen wäre es für sie halt ein Problem. Ich verstehe es nicht so ganz, weil es gibt schon ein fettes Server, aber weiß der Gaia, wie beliebt das wirklich ist. Und wenn da erstmal so eine Million Leute sich draufstürzen, dann multipliziert sich das alles ganz garstig. Ich würde gerne noch mal auf eine andere Frage kommen, ob ihr euch da als Podcastverband auch schon mit beschäftigt habt. Das ist natürlich die generelle Frage mit Musik und Lizenz und Freiheit.
Und die beantworten wir nach den Nachrichten. Sagen wir schon mal, bleibst du dran Thomas? Thomas bleibt dran, der kennt sich aus, im Gegensatz zu mir.
Danke. Montag, sind Sonntag bei KenFM in Potsdam, kommen aus Hamburg und lassen die Puppen tanzen, die dann aber aus Berlin stammen. Die Rede ist von den Puppet Masters. Puppetmasters und Montag Sonntag bei KenFM. Und nicht vergessen, Obst sind unsere Freunde.
Sorgen sie dafür, dass niemand mithört.
KenFM, die Fritz-Radio-Show mit Ken Jepsen. Immer sonntags von 14 bis 18 Uhr. Live in den Fritz-Studios in Potsdam Babelsberg.
Und im Radio Fritz vom RBB 5 nach halb 12.
In Berlin hat die Bundeswehr ihr 50-jähriges Bestehen gefeiert. Das erste Mal in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik marschierten am Abend Soldaten zu einem großen Zapfenstreich vor dem Reichstagsgebäude auf. Rund 1500 Bundeswehrgegner beteiligten sich an Demonstrationen. Union und SPD wollen die Kronzeugenregelung wieder einführen. Die Regel ermöglicht es, Straftäter frei zu sprechen oder milder zu bestrafen, wenn sie durch ihre Aussagen helfen, ein Verbrechen aufzuklären. Außerdem haben Union und SPD heute die Eckpunkte für Sparmaßnahmen im Bundeshaushalt festgelegt. Die internationale Gemeinschaft hat Pakistan zusätzliche Katastrophenhilfe zugesagt. Die UNU teilte mit, dass die Staaten zusätzlich 525 Millionen Dollar bereitstellen wollen. Fußball-Härte-BSC steht im Achtelfinale des DFB-Pokals. Die Berliner besiegten am Abend München-Gladbach mit 3 zu 0. Ausgeschieden ist dagegen Energie Cottbus, der Zweitligist unterlag bei Arminia Bielefeld 1 zu 2. Titelverteidiger Bayern München gewann bei Arzgebirge Auer 1 zu 0. Stuttgart und Duisburg schadeten dagegen an ihren Zweitliga-Gegnern. Stuttgart verloren Rostock 2 zu 3. Duisburg unterlag 1860 München mit dem gleichen Ergebnis. Am fünften Spieltag der Basketball-Liga gewann Alba Berlin in Karlsruhe 98 zu 67. In dieser Nacht wird das meist bedeckte höchste Verein seit etwas Regen bei 7 bis 11 Grad morgen dann erst einmal stark bewölkt. Im Laufe des Tages dann wieder die Sonne, jedenfalls manchmal bei 15 bis 19 Grad. Da erreicht man mir gerade frische Meldungen und zwar A12 blieb in der Ringrichtung Frankfurt zwischen Frankfurt West und dem Grenzebegang Frankfurt. Nach einem Unfall ist der rechte Fahrstreifen noch immer blockiert. Letzte freier Ausfahrt für Pkw ist Mühlrose und Autobahn 111. Autobahnzubringer Hamburg, drei Guranienburg Richtung Berlin, Charlottenburg. Zwischen Waldmanns-Lüsterdam, Hermsdorferdam und Kurt-Schumacher-Damm noch immer wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten Vollsperrung dieser Autobahn mitte der Umleitung folgen und unverändert Wildschweingefahr in Berlin. Treptow-Köpenick auf dem Adlergestell. Und zwar immer noch zwischen der Kreuzung Richterstraße und der Einmündung Fetschauer Allee mehrere Wildschweinrotten sind unterwegs.
Steht morgen wieder in der BZ.
Wildschwein-Terror am Adlergestell.
Vielen Dank Matthias Garcov, 8 Minuten nach 12.
Und wenn im Radio 91, 9, dann fritzt rund um Beld sich.
Bisüss Fritz ist an, Chaosradio 107 und das Thema ist Podcasting. Bei uns am Telefon ist immer noch der Thomas Warnhoff, der unter anderem herausgibt Warnhoffs wunderbare Welt der Wissenschaft und Gründungsmitglied und sogar ich glaube Präsident. Wie nennt man es Thomas? Vorsitzender, genau das war das Wort. Vorsitzender des Podcastverbandes ist, den ihr im Webbereich unter podcastverband.de und worum es jetzt gehen soll, im kleinen Interview mit Thomas Warnhoff ist, ja die rechte Frage, wie ist das eigentlich mit Musik, die du spielst? Spielst du Musik in Podcast?
Ja, ich spiele Musik. Ich habe sogar mit Musik, mit einem Musikpodcast angefangen vor ungefähr einem Jahr. Und man darf das auch, wenn man vorher fragt.
Wen fragt?
Vor allem die Künstler. Das ist das erste Mal das Wichtigste.
Das ist leider falsch.
Ihr macht mal, ich trinke ein Käffchen.
Ich muss erstmal den Künstler fragen. Hallo Künstler, bist du überhaupt Inhaber deiner Verwertungsrechte? Und wenn er sagt, ne bin ich nicht, das ist die G-Mail, dann kann ich dich nicht spielen.
Aber mal ehrlich, der durchschnittliche Künstler und ich meine das nicht böse, denn ich war lange Zeit selber einer, sag Doc, bist du überhaupt Inhaber deiner Verwertungsrechte?
Du warst ein durchschnittlicher Künstler?
Hab ich gesagt durchschnittlich?
Das haben auch andere gesagt.
Schön, dass du wieder bei uns bist.
Ahja.
Na, hat ja einen Grund, warum ich dann beim Radio gelandet bin.
Genau.
Das war das Gesicht.
Ich hab noch einen Fan.
Okay, also GEMA ist auf jeden Fall ein Doorstopper, das ist klar.
Also GEMA gemeldete Künstler, wenn ich sag, bist du bei der GEMA, dann sag ich ja, darf ich ihn nicht spielen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ja, das ist die Frage.
Du darfst ihn natürlich spielen, aber du müsstest dafür bezahlen. Du kannst ihn aber, selbst wenn du an den GEMA zahlst, schwerlich spielen, weil du nicht an die GVL zahlen kannst.
Ja, wenn er, glaub ich, dann einen Plattenvertrag auch noch hat, wird's richtig schwierig.
Was ist die GVL?
Gesellschaft für Verwertungsrechte.
Genau, ein weiterer Verwertungsverwertungsverwertung.
Leistungsschutz.
Ach so, Leistungsschutz. Okay, und das heißt, was müsste man da so bezahlen?
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen strittig. Die GEMA ist ja behördenartig strukturiert und hat was für Radio on Demand und für Radio on Stream, aber nicht für Podcasting. Uns sagen sie gar nichts, das ist schonmal das Erste. Die GEMA weigert sich überhaupt so richtig, mal was mitzuteilen, aber sie haben also bei anderen Anfragen durchblicken lassen, dass im Zweifel immer höchst als gilt und das sind dann bis zu so und so viel höheren muss ich dann so und so viel Euro bezahlen. Es wird einfach mächtig teuer und das ist nicht für den normalen Hobbypodcaster zu bezahlen. Das kann in die 1000 Euro gehen.
Also was natürlich fehlt, das große Problem an der GEMA ist, hast du gerade auch gesagt, dass es diese Beamtenmentalität und dass jede Entscheidung zwei, drei Jahre braucht. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo wir den endlichen Podcasting-Tarif haben von der GEMA, der sicher kommen wird, gibt es keinen Podcasting mehr. Also die GEMA schützt ja die Autoren, die schützt die Texte und die Leute, die die Musik komponiert haben, die nicht immer gleich sind mit den Leuten, die die Musik spielen.
Im letzter Zeit immer seltener.
Immer seltener. Denn die werden wiederum von der GVL geschützt. Das ist jetzt so die einfache Version. Und die GEMA, du kannst schon, das basiert auf diesen ersten Versuchen, Webradio zu machen vor vielen, vielen Jahren, als die Bandbreite noch nicht da war und deswegen alles sehr erfolglos war. Und deswegen hat die GEMA irgendwann den Unterschied gemacht, ja wenn es ein Stream ist, den ich nicht abspeichern kann auf meinem Computer sozusagen, was ich natürlich mit ein paar Tools trotzdem kann, aber egal, für die GEMA gibt es halt diesen Stream, das kann ich nur hören, aber nicht speichern, dann gibt es bestimmte Tarife. Und dann gibt es andere Tarife für den Download und klar ist ein Podcast ein Download. Wenn ich einen Song in einem Podcast spiele, der GEMA gemeldet ist, es gibt natürlich massig freie Musik, muss man gleich auch nochmal erwähnen, dann lade ich das Stück runter und habe es grundsätzlich, wenn auch in wahrscheinlich Nicht-CD-Qualität auf meinem Rechner und das ist für die GEMA ein Download, dafür gibt es schon auch Tarife, aber wie Thomas gerade gesagt hat, das ist sehr undurchsichtig, da gibt es mindestens sechs verschiedene Tarife, die dann auch nochmal aufgeteilt sind, je nach Höher und wie oft wird das runtergeladen und dann musst du deine gesamten Server-Statistiken quasi zugänglich machen für die GEMA und so, das ist alles ganz furchtbar. Das ist innovationshemmend.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das nagelt sich doch langsam aber sicher selbst ans Kreuz, dieses System.
Ja, also selbst wenn es da einen Weg gäbe, ist einfach ganz klar der Trend abzusehen, dass in der Podcastszene einfach derzeit der stärkste Sog erzeugt wird in Richtung freie Musik, die wir bisher hatten. Das ging ja mit den Radios schon los, aber jetzt ist es halt wirklich…
Was wir halt sehen, ist, dass sich Kulturgüter wie Musik und aber auch wie Filme und so, die werden sich in den nächsten Jahren, wird es eine Aufteilung geben in zwei Bereiche, nämlich der kommerzielle Bereich, der dann auch geschlossen ist für so Geschichten wie Podcasts oder so, weil das keiner bezahlen kann oder will. Und der andere Bereich, der zumindest was diese Dinge angeht, frei ist. Und wir werden zwei Arten von Kulturbereichen kriegen.
Ich glaube nicht mal, dass das unbedingt am Geld festgemacht werden muss. Also Podcasting kommt ja so ein bisschen aus der schon Independent-Geschichte oder so Anti-Mainstream-Richtung. Eine der Kritik am Radio war, ihr macht Mainstream, ihr spielt immer nur die gleichen Lieder und ihr macht immer nur das gleiche Radio und wir Podcaster, wir machen jetzt mal wieder Radio so, wie es früher war. Und deswegen, ich will überhaupt nicht Britney Spears oder so einen Unsinn bei mir spielen. Ich will nicht diesen ganzen Top 10 Kram haben, sondern ich will mal sehen, was es noch so tolle Sachen gibt. Und es gibt unglaublich viel gute Musik in Deutschland, die niemals die Chance hat, in irgendeinem Bayern-3 oder sowas Loop reinzukommen. Was? Und ich würde die gerne auch bezahlen. Also ich habe kein Problem mit einem Künstler zu sagen, hey pass auf, wenn ich in irgendeiner Form einen Werbebanner bei mir habe und spiele deinen Song, dann kriegst du was ab davon. Ist keine Sache, klar. Also gegen Kohle kann das schon sein.
Also das mit der unglaublich vielen freien Musik, ich muss zugeben, dass ich mich da jetzt nicht täglich sechs Stunden lang auseinandersetze, aber doch pro Woche zwei, drei Stunden in Sachen rein höre und so und ich finde auch immer wieder klasse Sachen, aber ich möchte da nicht ketzerisch klingen und ich weiß, dass wir uns dahin bewegen, es wird alles immer besser, aber es ist schon immer noch ein Problem mit der freien Musik, denn Popkultur hat nicht nur mit dem reinen Klang zu tun. Denn Popkultur ist auch das ganze drumrum und wenn ich von nicht freier, also lizenzierter Musik im Sinne von GEMA-Mitgliedern und GVL-Mitgliedern und so rede, dann rede ich ja nicht nur von Britney Spears, sondern rede ich von 30, 40 Jahren Popgeschichte.
Hotel Tokio.
Genau, solche Grandiose. Nein, aber dann rede ich ja auch von Dingen, selbst eine Band wie Hüsker Dü kann ich nicht spielen, mehr Underground kann man kaum sein oder Fugazi und so weiter und so fort. Auch diese Dinge sind gemeldet bei irgendwelchen Lizenzunternehmen.
Ja, aber es gibt auch echt gute Ausnahmen. Natürlich gibt es die, klar. Ich bin da jetzt leider auch kein Experte, aber ich habe mir jetzt in den letzten Tagen auch noch mal ein bisschen geforscht und will hier auch mal eine Quelle von großartiger freier Musik, die ich entdeckt habe, nicht unerwähnt lassen und zwar solltet ihr alle mal euch auf Starfrosch.ch tummeln. Da gibt es zwei Jungs, Kuss und Ossi, die sich ganz eifrig bemühen, insbesondere im Elektronikerbereich, aber nicht nur dort. Da gibt es ganz viele Musikkategorien. Ich habe das bei Live noch nicht alles durchgehört, aber da gibt es halt RSS-Feeds, also quasi Podcastartige Feeds, wo einfach nur Musik rausfällt den ganzen Tag. Das ist so ein bisschen die Essenz aus dieser Net-Audio, Net-Label-Kultur.
Leider ist ja leider ein Problem von Podcasts und dem Internet generell. Das Problem hat das herkömmliche Radio und Fernsehen nicht. Es ist egal, wie viele Milliarden Zuschauer zusehen, das wird nicht langsam machen.
Ja, okay, da können wir übrigens auch gleich noch mal reden, was diese Bandbreitenproblematik gibt. Da gibt es auch noch eine technische Antwort. Aber um kurz mal bei der Musik zu bleiben, ich habe da in den letzten Tagen reingehört, ich habe jetzt leider nicht genug Zeit gehabt, auch so richtig mir was rauszusuchen, aber alles, was ich gehört habe, klang super. Also das war zumindest mein Musikgeschmack elektronischer Hinsicht, wurde da ganz gut bedient.
Ja, aber genau da hast du ja, ich sage mal, zumindest ein Anführungszeichen das Problem, was es so an freier Musik gibt, ist, zumindest nach meiner Wahrnehmung, ich sage mal 70-80 Prozent wirklich elektronische Musik, ganz, ganz wenig Pop nur. Also einfacher, schöner Pop und ein bisschen Hip-Hop.
Also echt Pop brauche ich nicht. Ja du? Ja ich und eine ganze Menge anderer Leute auch und Pop ist halt per se populär und spielt von daher in einer anderen Liga.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das würde ich jetzt mal so, wenn du dir so Netlabels anguckst wie Ideology zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht ob du den kennst, ideology.de, die haben eben ein paar Popsachen da, wo eben ganz normal Menschen eine Gitarre spielen und dazu Lieder singen. Das rubriziere ich dann in dem Moment auch mal unter Pop.
Pop ist für mich…
Also es gibt schon einen Haufen Sachen, also guckt euch mal international an, was da in diesem Podsave Music Network passiert, da sind richtig große Nummern zum Teil dabei. Es gibt bei Magna Tune, ist auch international so ein Label, wo man Podsave Music spielen kann, da sind auch richtig gute Sachen dabei und selbst bei mp3.de kann man die ein oder andere Perle finden.
Weißt du, was aber ein grundsätzliches Problem ist, mir ist total egal, ob diese Musik frei ist oder auf McDonalds Music erschienen ist, das ist mir einfach wurscht. Und das ist halt, da sehe ich, ich sehe da schon, also ich glaube, dass wir noch ein paar Jahre brauchen werden, weil ich sehe da schon ein Problem drin, dass wir langsam anfangen, dass ich sage, ich gehe zu Podsave Music und da gibt es echt tolle Sachen. Aber das ist, ich möchte nicht meine Musik danach auswählen, die ich in einem Podcast zum Beispiel spiele, ob die bei einem Label ist oder nicht.
Oder bei was für einem Label ist es zu stehen? Ich bin da eigentlich sehr optimistisch, was das betrifft. Ich glaube ja fest daran, dass die anderen sich mit ihrer GEMA-Verfnaudung und so weiter einfach selber ihren Käfig bauen, aus dem sind irgendwann nicht mehr rauskommen, weil einfach die Kultur schreit danach, frei zu sein. Und bei Musik ist das einfach extrem und mit Podcasting wird das jetzt ganze multipliziert, wenn nicht sogar potenziert. Und mit dem Ergebnis, dass einfach mal das, was sich selber zu sehr regeln setzt, verbreitet zu werden, dann irgendwann auch einfach untergebuttert wird durch das, was frei ist. Weil es geht ja auch um kopieren können, um remixen können, um neu verwerten. So gerade im Podcast sehen wir jetzt diese...
Für die Masse der User geht es darum nicht. Für die Masse der User geht es einschalten, nutzen.
Nicht der User, der Leute, die Musik machen.
Wir haben in Deutschland noch viel zu kleine Podcasts, was die Downloadzahlen angeht. Wenn ich in Deutschland eine Show habe, die 30.000, 40.000, 50.000 Downloads hat und da spiele ich mal eine Band eine Zeit lang, dann kann das schon Effekte haben, aber natürlich.
Ja, das kann Effekte haben, aber wir dürfen... Ich bin natürlich ideologisch komplett bei Tim, das ist überhaupt keine Frage, und ich bin großer Verfechter von Creative Commons und diesen ganzen Ansätzen, ich halte die für extrem wichtig. Ich glaube auch, dass sie immer immer wichtiger werden, aber unterhalte ich mal mit Netlabel-Betreibern zum Beispiel, und die werden dir alle sagen, und das ist auch ein Punkt, den man nicht vergessen darf, die werden dir alle sagen, die Bands sind super gerne bei uns, die geben auch ihre mp3s gerne raus, wenn das zum Beispiel gleichzeitig auch noch ein DJ ist, der elektronische Musik macht, der kriegt vielleicht dadurch mal ein Engagement als DJ und so weiter, der hat davon Nutzen, aber wenn du eine Band hast, die auf einem Netlabel sozusagen kostenlos veröffentlicht und auf ein paar Gigs hofft oder auf ein paar verkaufte T-Shirts, sobald der erste Verlag ankommt und sagt, hier sind 10.000 Euro Vorschuss, unterschreiben die. Weil sie müssen und wollen davon leben. Musik ist ihre Leidenschaft, das wollen sie tun. Wir reden jetzt nicht von den manufactured products, von irgendwelchen Produkten, sondern wir reden einfach von, egal in welcher Musikrichtung, von Leuten, die eine Leidenschaft für Musik haben, die diese Musik machen wollen und müssen und auch irgendwann nach vielen, vielen Jahren mal und sei es nur eine Monatsrate für ihre Wohnung bezahlen wollen, die werden unterzeichnen. Man kann nicht einfach immer nur sagen, ich bin kein Freund der GEMA, weil sie sich so langsam bewegt und so, aber es hat eine Historie, diese ganze Urheberrechtsgeschichte und so weiter und so fort, die man auch nicht einfach vom Tisch fegen kann und es macht durchaus Sinn, dass auch intellektuelle Produkte in irgendeiner Art und Weise geschützt werden.
Sie werden aber nicht von der GEMA geschützt, Vorsicht. Die GEMA holt die Kohle. Also geschützt werden sie immer noch vom Urheberrecht. Und das ist auch richtig so. Ich bin aber auch nicht dagegen, wenn Bands Verträge unterschreiben und wenn es um Geld geht. Nur es muss auf einer fairen Basis sein. Und diese Möglichkeit haben wir zurzeit nicht.
Da bin ich völlig mit dir in Dekor.
Ich denke, Podcasting ist ein weiterer Schritt. Diese Sache mit freier Musik und Vertrieb und alternativer Verkauf vorbei an großen Strukturen, die komplex und teuer sind, den Traum haben wir jetzt schon lange. Und wir haben irgendwie schon vor zehn Jahren auf den Tisch getrommelt. Und da haben sich halt alle noch gefragt, ja wieso Downloads und überhaupt. Und da reicht ja noch nicht mal die Bandbreite. Und dann reicht ja irgendwann die Bandbreite und dann naja ein Netradius und so und das hört ja keiner. So jetzt sind wir irgendwie die nächste Stufe wird genommen mit Podcasting und ich sag dir nächstes Jahr werden einfach scheiße viele Leute werden Podcasts hören. Richtig, richtig fett wird das abgehen. Und dann ist wieder eine Stufe genommen. Und wir werden dann irgendwann es auch sehen und das wird kommen, ich kann dir nicht sagen, wer jetzt hier da den größten Erfolg haben wird, wer den Schritt macht, ob das Apple ist mit seinem iTunes Store oder jemand anders noch mal auf eine großartige Idee kommt. Ich bin zutiefst davon überzeugt, dass einfach der Direct Sales von dem Künstler zum Kunden irgendwann hergestellt sein wird und dann werden diese Systeme halt auch in Frage gestellt. Also Creative Commons ist dabei ein wichtiger Player derzeit, weil die überhaupt auch erst mal dieses Verständnis formulieren, dieses ich erlaube explizit das private Kopieren, das redistributieren, ich will, dass ich verteilt werde und ich will mich nicht von vornherein in irgendein Käfig sperren lassen. Das ist jetzt auch der wichtige Beitrag zu dieser kulturellen Diskussion, damit das überhaupt erst mal, dass die Leute wach werden. Und wenn ich mir so, ich will jetzt nicht schon wieder Adam Curry sagen, aber ich sag's, er spielt ja auch Musik, er stellt auch die ganze Zeit Musik vor aus diesem Podsave-Music-Network. Er hat das ja auch mit angestoßen und Künstler stellen dort eben ihre Musik auch bewusst ein. Das ist ja auch ein bewusster Schritt und bei Starfrosch, ich hab eigentlich gerne mich mit den Leuten ja auch noch mal im Telefon, wenn ihr zufällig zuhört, vielleicht könnt ihr noch mal anrufen.
Sag mal die Nummer noch mal.
0331 70 97 110 in Deutschland dann, ne?
Ja, unser Podcast hat ja den Vorteil, dass er auch live ist. Das ist vielleicht auch etwas, das sicherlich kommen wird. Aber jetzt zweige ich ab. Das will ich gar nicht.
Was halt gerade passiert, was halt ganz spannend ist, da wo E-Mail vielleicht eine Renaissance des Briefe-Schreibens war und ist, da wo Webblogs vielleicht die Renaissance des Schreibens, Selberschreibens und Lesens ist, da sind Podcasts eine Renaissance des wirklich Zuhörendes. Denn das Radio, das herkömmliche Radio ist im Moment eine, und das sagen ja die Radios selber auch, ein Tagesbegleitprogramm. Das heißt, du stehst morgens auf und da sagst auch im Hintergrund einer, es ist 7.43 Uhr, jetzt haben wir aber alle inzwischen Uhren und deswegen ist das vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so wichtig. Einen Podcast wirst du nie morgens beim Frühstück mit der Familie hören. Der Witz ist, der Witz ist, vielleicht wird sich das auch entwickeln.
Leute hören sogar Chaosradio morgens beim Frühstück.
Die Leute wollen sogar Radio hören, das ihnen was erzählt und das kein Tagesbegleitmedium ist. Das ist der Witz an der Sache. Die Art und Weise, wie Hörerzahlen in Deutschland ermittelt werden, nämlich über Telefonumfragen, die ermitteln ja tatsächlich nur, welches Plakat hast du gestern am häufigsten gesehen und darum wirst du sagen, welchen Sender du hörst. Die, die sich am schärfsten als Tagesbegleitmedium positionieren, die kleben natürlich die größten Plakate. Die Schweiz ist hingegangen und hat sich von diesen Telefoninterviews blöd verabschiedet und hat ein wesentlich objektivierbares Mittel gefunden, Hörerzahlen zu ermitteln. Das ist nämlich eine Armbanduhr, die ähnlich einem GfK-Gerät zu Hause am Fernseher an deinem Handgelenk ist über 14 Tage oder vier Wochen und die ganze Zeit aufzeichnet, was hörst du für Sender? Dazu ist die offensichtlich in der Lage und dabei ist rausgekommen, dass die Leute genau dann, wenn jemand im Radio was sagt, hinhören und genau dann, wenn es nur dudelt, ausschalten. Das war ein Interview, das ich gehört habe mit dem Kulturradio, ich glaube vom DRS, die gesagt haben, wir haben unser Programm wieder umgekrempelt. Also so wie in Deutschland gerade Kulturradios geschliffen werden, wo wirklich dann im Grunde nur noch Klassik im Hintergrund dudelt und bloß nicht mehr als fünf Minuten Wort. Genau davon kommen die Schweizer jetzt wieder ab, weil sie ihre Hörerzahlen anders ermitteln. Das heißt, zuhören ist eigentlich wirklich ein Wunsch, das wollen die Leute.
Ich glaube trotzdem, dass das gerade deswegen natürlich nicht die seit 1 RTL keine Ahnung Mainstream-Massen erreichen wird, was auch gut ist, weil viele Medienangebote, die übers Netz kommen und eben nicht über die bisher bekannten alten Kanäle, sind Nischenangebote, die aber in den einzelnen Nischen wieder eine Masse ausmachen.
Aber guck mal, was RTL anbietet, das ist Comedy.
Ja, ne, die machen noch was ganz anderes, guckt euch doch mal bitte die Dokus an. Guckt euch mal an Tiersendungen oder was, das ist Podcasting, was die machen, im Fernsehen.
Warum?
Das sind Sachen, wo ich lange, wo ich zugucke, wo es nicht mehr nur um die ganz doofe Doku-Soap bigwappermäßig geht, sondern gerade auch diese Massen-Sendungen oder Sender machen ganz lange Dokumentationssendungen, da laufen die BBC-Geschichten bei Vox und bei ProSieben sogar. Das ist was, wo die Leute wieder sagen, hey, ich nehme die Zeit und gucke mir das in aller Ruhe an. Das passiert in der Tat beim Podcasting auch. Ich hab, meine Sendung dauert eine halbe Stunde, das lädt sich keiner runter, der nebenbei Unterhaltung haben will.
Es geht um ein Grundbedürfnis der Menschen, meine ich, und zwar das Grundbedürfnis, Geschichten erzählt zu bekommen. Egal, ob es jetzt was Informatives, was Unterhaltsames ist oder ob es ein Doku ist. Und das entdecken natürlich auch die Privaten, aus den Gründen, die Holgi gerade beschrieben hat, wieder. Das ist ein ganz altes Bedürfnis der Menschheit, als wir noch in Höhlen waren, wollte ich gerade sagen. Früher gab es die Geschichtenerzähler, die von Dorf zu Dorf gegangen sind, also wie hießen die? Bänkelsänger, Stadtschreiber, Chronisten, was hat das zu tun? Es gab keine Zeitungen, sondern die Leute sind hin und her gelaufen und haben die Geschichte erzählt. Dann hat sie den anderen falsch weitererzählt und hat das ganz große draus gemacht.
Das waren die Weblogs von damals.
Ganz genau. Nicht ganz, weil der eine wesentliche Unterschied damals und auch der eine wesentliche Unterschied zum normalen Broadcasting ist, du hast ein Gemeinschaftserlebnis. Und das hast du natürlich nicht mehr beim Webbloggen, beim Podcasten.
Beim Webbloggen aber in irgendeiner Form schon durch die Kommentare.
In einer neuen Form. Aber du hast eben deine Peergroup, in der du dich bewegst und aus der du dich nie rausbewegst oder nur sehr selten und sehr schwierig rausbewegen kannst. Und das glaube ich, haben dann die Massenmedien immer noch als Vorteil. Und ich glaube auch nur da können sie überleben, wenn sie sagen, okay, wir sind ein Gemeinschaftsgedöns.
Ein ganz großes Problem von diesen ganzen Medien ist und da ich mache gerade Pause auf Spreeblick und ich grübele darüber, ich finde ein ganz großes Problem, ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Spreeblick Problem ist oder von vielen Webblogs, ich glaube von vielen Webblogs ist, du kommst als Neuankömmling super schwer in die ganzen Sachen rein. Und zwar einfach nicht, dass du nicht verstehst, wie das geht, wie man einen Podcast runterlädt oder wie man einen Blog liest oder so. Aber es wird irgendwann so eine Szene in Anführungsstrichen, egal wie groß oder wie klein die ist. Du musst den Autor erstmal kennenlernen und so weiter. Du findest einen unglaublich schweren Einstieg und das ist auch eine Designfrage bei Weblogs, wie komme ich eigentlich an einen der alten 1500 Artikel, die dann noch irgendwo stehen und vielleicht auch ganz spannend sind, dran? Was mir immer bewusst wird, wenn ich gucke, über welche Google-Suchbegriffe die Leute zu mir kommen. Und das ist auch mit Podcasts und so weiter an sich das, was das klassische Radio, das klassische Fernsehen, die klassische Zeitung schon lange weiß, wo wir wahrscheinlich über uns lachen. Aber wie kann ich eigentlich dem Neuankömmling, der zum ersten Mal diese Zeitung in die Hand nimmt, der zum ersten Mal Fritz einschaltet, der zum ersten Mal ARD einschaltet, wie kann ich den herzlich willkommen heißen?
Indem du immer wieder neu einordnest, was du tust. Und zwar idealerweise jedes Mal, wenn du den Mund aufmachst. Und das, also Orientierung zu bieten, das ist ja was du willst. Du willst ja Orientierung bieten in dem Moment. Also Orientierung auf dein Produkt. Und das ist eben die große Kunst, das idealerweise in drei Sätzen zu machen. Dann würde nämlich jeder wissen, dass wir über Podcasts reden und nicht über Internetradio.
Ist nicht gerade Zeit für den Jingle.
Chaosradio 107, immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat von Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Und es geht um Podcasting. Also es geht nicht um Internetradios, weil also der Einbeinige an der Hotline sagte eben mir auf meinen Kopf, die Leute glauben, hier ging es um Internetradios. Das ist längst rum. Also es geht mittlerweile um Podcasting, was ja im Grunde nichts anderes ist als ein automatisiertes Runterladen von Audiodateien und zwar immer dann, wenn es ein Update der Audiodatei gibt, dann kommt es automatisch auf dem Rechner zu Hause an.
Oder auf Video.
Oder auf Video mittlerweile.
Da gibt es auch noch viel zu erzählen.
Übrigens, Thomas zu erzählen.
Am Telefon immer noch Thomas Warnhoff von der wunderbaren Welt der Wissenschaft Podcast. Einfach mal googeln, dann habt ihr es sofort. Und auch vom Podcastverband und vielen, vielen anderen Aktivitäten. Thomas, du hattest mir, als wir gestern gemailt haben und ich gefragt habe, hast du gesagt, aber nicht so spät, dann seht mal zu, dass es so gegen elf ist. Das heißt, wenn du was besseres vorhast, als mit uns drei hier zu broadcasten.
Meine Gastgeberin macht mir gerade das Bett hier in dem Wohnzimmer, wo ich in München mal übernachten darf.
Gut, findest du das nicht sexistisch?
Kannst du dir dein Bett nicht selber machen, Sander?
Ich glaube, ich schalte dein Mikrofon einfach wieder aus.
Da gibt es doch diesen doofen Witz mit der Kaffeetasse, wo irgendwie so ein Chef an seinem Tisch sitzt und die Sekretärin rührt ihm gerade den Kaffee um und er sagt, finden sie das nicht sexistisch, wenn sie den auch noch umrühren?
Thomas, wir bedanken uns. Genau.
Wir wünschen dir einen guten Abend.
Vielen Dank, dass du mitgemacht hast, vielen Dank, dass du Rede und Antwort gestanden hast und nichts für ungut, dass wir dir so oft über den Mund gefahren sind.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Genau, und du kannst uns ja dann morgen in deinem Podcast verhackstücken.
Ich mache euch fertig.
Das war Thomas Warnhoff von Warnhoffs wunderbare Welt der Wissenschaft oder Podcasting Verband. Idealerweise findet ihr ihn unter www.warnhoff.de mit Links zu allem, was er sonst noch so an Aktivitäten treibt. Chaosradio 107, Podcasting unser Thema und man davon abgesehen, dass ich ja vielleicht auch mal irgendwann selber einen Podcast machen wollen würde.
Kannst ja mal ein paar Gast-Sendungen bei mir machen.
Ein paar Gast-Sendungen bei dir. Also ich könnte, wie wär's denn den Holgi-Rant der Woche? Also so einmal in der Woche komm ich vorbei und lass mal so richtig Dampf ab.
Ja, kannst du nicht einmal die Woche irgendwie so einen 30 Sekunden aufnehmen?
Klar, absolut.
Bist du sofort. Herzlich willkommen Holgi.
Ich komm nochmal ganz groß raus aus dem Geschäft. Dann würde mich ja schon interessieren, also andersrum, ich hab den Überblick verloren. Also ich hab im Podcastbereich schon den Überblick verloren und bin noch nicht mehr in der Lage, mir vernünftig was zusammenzustellen, was deutschsprachig ist, weil das irgendwie schon wieder zehn Stunden dauert, bis ich da mal durchgescrollt bin.
Also die Zeit ist garantiert ein Problem, finde ich. Und ich war vorhin ja auch schwer beeindruckt vor der Sendung, als Tim hat extrem viel recherchiert und ich meine, dass ich mich erinnern kann, dass du irgendwann vor ein paar Wochen in einem Chat oder Telefonat gesagt hast, dass dich irgendwas noch nicht so richtig umhaut. Und in den letzten Tagen hat sich das aber scheinbar doch sehr geändert mit deiner Recherche. Ich war vorhin extrem beeindruckt von allem, was du gezeigt hast. Und zwar, da kommen wir dann auch mal zu der Video-Version des Castings, sozusagen. Weil Tim hat, was war das da so, aus der eigenen Perspektive gefilmt, dieses Ding? Nein, das war mit der Frau, die das Glied von dem Mann, also extrem beeindruckend. Nein, also Leute, Tim hat es.
Extrem beeindruckend.
Okay, wir reden nachher auch noch ein bisschen über Porno, ist natürlich hier auch noch ein Thema. Und das ist übrigens auch, bleiben wir bei Porno. Das ist eines der Signale, dass das hier abgeht mit dieser Technologie, weil das natürlich zur Porno-Distribution, insbesondere zur bezahlten Porno-Distribution, ein optimales Medium ist, bis hin zu einem Video-Abspielgerät.
Ich finde das irgendwie nicht optimal, wenn Apple über die iTunes-Abrechnung weiß, was für Filme ich brauche.
Nein, nein, nein, das läuft natürlich nach wie vor, wie sie das auch sonst machen, über Kreditkarte. Das heißt, du machst da quasi dein Abo auf und dann ist dein Feed von Frischporn einfach aus dem Web, da hat Apple nichts mehr zu tun. Darum geht es ja irgendwie. Die Leute wollen ja dann immer wieder was Neues sehen. Keine Ahnung, ich stecke da auch nicht so drin. Aber ich habe schon immer die Erkenntnis gehabt, Porno ist da, wo die erfolgreichen Technologien sind. Alles setzt sich nur durch, wenn da auch Porno drauf funktioniert. Das ist mit der CD so, das ist mit VHS so, das ist mit DVD so.
Also Letzteres stimmt, dass es sich dadurch durchsetzt. Aber grundsätzlich ist die Pornoindustrie natürlich diejenige, die auf jede Technologie setzt, weil es könnte ja sein.
Also ich glaube, dann würden sie auch podcasten. Tun sie ja. Ja, mit Video, aber nicht Audio, oder? Gibt es Stimmen?
Nein, es gibt ganz viel.
Na, das kommt bestimmt auch noch.
Nein, es gibt ja diese Telefon-Sticks. Explicit Sex-Podcasts und so. Das Problem ist, bei einem normalen Podcast kannst du im Moment kein Geld verdienen. Das ist für die Pornoindustrie uninteressant.
Natürlich kannst du damit. Ich meine, wenn du denen den Feed nur anbietest, wenn dafür bezahlt wird, dann kannst du das sehr wohl tun. Die Frage ist nur, wie findest du da deine Kunden? Derzeit probieren sie es halt erst mal mit so ein bisschen freien Bilderchen über so ein Public Feed. Und wenn du mehr musst, du bezahlst. Das ist relativ einfach zu machen.
Furspawn.de ist übrigens noch nicht registriert. Ich finde ihn doch mal entzündlich grandios. Kannst du haben. Wer erst registriert, der hat erst den nächsten Film gewonnen.
Ja, also ich habe mal so ein bisschen recherchiert und wo fand ich nicht so angetan, wo ich mir auch ein bisschen mit schwer tue, aber das ging mir übrigens bei Webblogs am Anfang auch so, dass ich eigentlich so mit dem deutschen Teil noch nicht so richtig klar komme. Weiß ich auch nicht so ganz genau, warum. Da ist halt noch sehr viel Tagebuch-Style. Da wird vor allem noch sehr viel von dem kopiert, was jetzt in der englischsprachigen Welt schon Erfolg hat. Das ist ja auch verständlich. Bloß von daher reizt es mich vielleicht nicht so sehr. Dazu kommt, dass glaube ich der Durst nach Podcasting in den USA einfach sehr viel größer ist. Hat man ja auch schon erwähnt, weil dort einfach die Qualität des öffentlichen Fernsehs und Radios einfach mal noch einfach da niederliegt. Und die Leute dürsten geradezu nach Informationen. Außerdem Verbreitung Internet und so weiter. Das kennt man ja alles, das trägt ganz extrem dazu bei. Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es natürlich auch hier schöne Sachen. Aber ich will mal so ein bisschen erzählen, was es gibt. Vor allem noch mal kurz erwähnen, was man so auch vom Chaos Computer Club alles so empfangen kann. Also abgesehen davon, dass wir uns jetzt hier noch einen kleinen Feed eingerichtet haben, das ist ja keine wirkliche Nachricht, kann man auch andere Chaosradios, Chaosradioartige Sendungen aus dem CCC-Umfeld auch schon über Podcasting empfangen. Zum Beispiel das Def Radio aus Ulm oder Radio Chaotica aus Karlsruhe. Haupt nicht, wenn ich jetzt noch einen vergessen habe. Es gibt ja noch mehr Sendungen aus unserem Umfeld, wo halt so ein bisschen nerdkompatibel berichtet wird. Es gibt in Köln zum Beispiel auch ein McHackers Podcast, der leider etwas wenig gepflegt wird. Vielleicht kommt das noch. In New York gibt es dann wiederum 2600, die ja schon seit langer, langer Zeit Radio machen. Off the Hook, eine wöchentliche Sendung, übrigens auch immer mittwochs. Auch das gibt es mittlerweile als Podcast. Und wir werden auch bei unserem Kongress Ende des Jahres, Chaos Communication Kongress, vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember hier in Berlin, wird es Berichterstattung geben, live von der Veranstaltung oder Podcast. Ob wir dann auch unsere Vortragsaufzeichnung oder Podcasts verbreiten, weiß ich nicht. Will ich jetzt mal nicht ausschließen, aber schon gar nicht möchte ich das garantieren an dieser Stelle. Ja, womit wir auch so ein bisschen bei diesem Video Podcasting wären. Ich hab da halt mal so ein bisschen rumgeschaut. Und als der iPod mit Videofähigkeit angekündigt wurde, war das natürlich auch ein heißes Thema. Und da hab ich auch noch mal ein bisschen hinterhergeklickt und war recht überrascht, wie groß diese Video Podcasting oder Videologger oder Vlogger-Szene schon ist. Da geschieht doch eine ganze Menge. Und es gibt auch ein paar echt schöne Sachen. Ich will jetzt hier keine URLs runterbeten, die hab ich mir auch gar nicht notiert, aber vielleicht mal so ein paar Namen, wo ihr nachher suchen könnt, die wirklich schick sind, wo man so einen ganz guten Eindruck davon bekommt, was es alles gibt. Also das setzt sich zusammen aus so Hobbyfilmern, aber auch Leute, die so Kurzfilme machen, lustiges Zeug, Animationen, aber auch mal so Mitschnitte von irgendwelchen Guerilla-Performances auf der Straße. Sehr schön finde ich 90 Minutes of Dave. Das gibt es auch bei iTunes zu suchen. Sehr schöne Sachen, da hat er gerade mit so einer Serie, einer 15-teiligen Serie angefangen, wo sozusagen alle paar Tage kommt eine neue Episode von so einem 15-teiligen Gesamtwerk. Das läuft gerade, ist recht spannend. Sehr schönes Zeug, auch lustiges, gibt es bei Agent Xenon zu betrachten. blip.tv, das ist so ein komplettes Video-Logging-Portal. Da gibt es so einen Hauptfeed, wo alle Video-Logs zusammengeschmissen werden. Das ist einfach nur noch irre, was da kommt. Aber sehr aufgeschlossen ist auch die VJ-Szene für Podcasting, weil hier natürlich auch mal ein sehr guter Weg gefunden ist, seine Kunst zu zeigen. Also bei VJs, das ist ja noch eine sehr verkannte Kulturdisziplin, wo sehr viel schönes Zeug erzeugt wird. Und es gibt so ein paar VJ-Feeds, ich muss noch mal gucken, habe mir keine Urls notiert, wo halt so Live-Mitschnitte von Parties, also wo dann auch schon das VJ-Work, was ja immer in Echtzeit abgemischt wird, bei den guten VJs mit der Musik dann aufgezeichnet wird und dann als Podcast verbreitet wird, oder auch einfach Rohmaterial kommt. Also wo auch unter freien Lizenzen verbreitete Videoclips kommen, die dann quasi unter Namensnennungsbedingungen, also wiederum in anderen Werken, eingebaut werden kann. Und so ähnlich wie das mit Audio schon läuft, geht das eben jetzt mit Video auch los. Und da ist Podcasting auf jeden Fall auch eine Hilfe in der Distribution. Ist auch sehr schön bequem anzuschauen. Ja, es gibt so viel. Sehr schön ist auch Big Time TV. Das ist auch eine sehr gute Zusammenstellung von Videoschnipseln. humandog.com mit Bindestrich auch sehr zu empfehlen. Das lastminuteblog.com ebenfalls. Und zwei Sachen vielleicht noch. Maya Entertainment mit E. Und momentshowing.net oder.com. Da kommen also einfach, kann ich schwer beschreiben. Es sind lustige Clips, auch ein bisschen spaciges Zeug, verrückte Sachen. Also es ist alles sehr inspirierend. Und man sieht auch, dass es alles noch in sehr Bewegung ist. Aber es wird einfach berichtet. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch falsch.
Gibt es irgendwo eine Linkliste dazu?
Ich werde mich bemühen, das hier in unsere Mitmachseite, in der Wikipedia, die unter chaosradio.ccc.de verlinkt ist, noch nachzutragen. Ich hatte jetzt, da ich bis kurz vor der Sendung hier noch am Recherchieren war, keine Gelegenheit gehabt, das alles zu machen. Aber ich werde zusehen, dass ich das alles noch unterbringe.
Wie findest du denn diese Video-Podcasts, also die Vlogs auf iTunes? Weil wenn ich zum Beispiel 90 Minutes eingebe...
90 Minutes of Dave ist da sogar gefeaturet.
Im Podcast-Verzeihungs?
Podcast, da gibt es da oben so Video-Podcasts und da steht es drin. 90 Minutes mit 90 glaube ich geschrieben. Oder gib es einfach mal bei Google ein.
Of Fame oder?
Ja, es gibt auch für Nerds so einiges Lustiges. Es gibt so diverse Programmierer-Sachen. Hier für den Mac gerade entdeckt, Coco Radio. Aber auch der Dave Weiner, der diesen ganzen RSS-Klimbim angefacht hat. Der berichtet immer schön morgens von seinem Kaffeepult aus mit seinem Morning Coffee. Das ist wahrscheinlich so das älteste Podcasting überhaupt, weil er macht das seit 2003. Aber auch so für aktuelle Technologien, Ruby on Rails, gerade so ein extrem zu Recht gehyptes Programmier-Framework für Web-Anwendungen. Auch da wurde gleich ein Podcast angefangen. Also man sieht richtig, wie Podcasts wie Wikis und Webblogs jetzt aufgenommen werden, um einfach auch eine Community-Bindung zu machen. Sehr viele Interviews mit den Leuten, die in diesen Projekten aktiv sind. Und dadurch, dass man eben auch einfach mal die Stimmen hört und man auch irgendwie was anderes erzählt, als man es in einen Webblog schreiben würde, entsteht dadurch eine Nähe und eine Wärme, wie du da vorhin auch schon gesagt hast. Das ist auch so mein Eindruck, der den Unterschied ausmacht bei diesem Medium. Wer schon immer Interesse an Slashdot hatte, aber keine Zeit hat, sich das alles durchzulesen, für den gibt es zum Beispiel das Slashdot Daily Review Podcast, wo die Leute tatsächlich jeden Tag zusammenfassen, was auf Slashdot so an Nachrichten gelaufen ist und auch was an interessanten Kommentaren dazu gekommen ist. Oh Gott, die Liste ist so lang. Und was ich auch extrem beeindruckend fand, so Special Audiences habe ich das mal hier zusammengefasst, also so Podcasts, die wirklich überhaupt nicht in die Breite gehen, aber die einfach aus interessanten Szenen berichten. Zum Beispiel gibt es den Cockpitcast, wo irgendwie ein Langstreckenpilot die Funkgespräche der Piloten auf dem Pazifischen Ozean, wo die Frequenzen, die normalerweise zur Diskussion mit den Tauern und der Flugsicherung, also diese Frequenzen, die normalerweise dafür benutzt werden, sind auf dem Pazifischen Ozean einfach frei, weil da gibt es halt keine Towers, da ist halt einfach nur Ozean. Und dann wird da eben gechattet. Und der zeichnet das halt auf und berichtet auch ansonsten irgendwie aus dem Cockpit. Das sind schon ganz interessante Einblicke.
Das heißt 90 seconds of Dave.
Was habe ich denn gesagt?
Minutes.
Ich suche mich hier blöd.
Oh, Entschuldigung, tut mir leid.
Man macht ja nichts.
cockpitcastblogspot.com, oder was ist das denn?
Kann sein. Wie gesagt, ich habe mir nur die Namen aufgeschrieben, gerade nicht die OS. Die habe ich alle in meinem iTunes, aber der rückt das ja nicht so ohne weiteres wieder heraus. Da ist dann heute auch gleich das erste Video aufgetaucht von einer Landung. Da wurde wohl nachgefragt. Also jetzt fangen sie auch noch an, aus dem Cockpit zu filmen. Das ist alles ganz interessant. Drivetime ist so ein verrückter Typ, der irgendwie das Podcasting in seinem Auto betreibt. Der hat irgendwie die Kamera vorne an der Frontscheibe installiert und nimmt immer irgendwelche Leute mit und unterhält sich mit denen. Auch ganz interessant. Dann gibt es so spezialisierte Video-Shows schon richtig, die halt Produkttests machen. So für die DV-Szene DV Gear zum Beispiel, wo dann immer so aktuelle Produkte getestet werden oder wo auch immer ganz konkret gezeigt wird, wie man dieses und jenes Problem mit Mikrofonen und so weiter lösen kann. Also so Hands-on-Tutorials in die Richtung. Und natürlich tonnenweise Computerkram, Macintosh-Szene stürzt sich natürlich auch wie wild auf Podcasting, sowohl in Audio- als auch in Video-Hinsicht.
Wie kommt's?
Ach na ja, ich meine, in der Macintosh-Szene ist man natürlich erstmal sehr exponentiefreudig. Und dadurch, dass Apple natürlich da auch so an der Vorfront ist, wird es einfach aufgenommen. Also auch Webblogs waren natürlich in der Macintosh-Szene am Anfang viel, viel, viel stärker. Auch das Web. Also es gab Web-Editoren auf dem Mac und so weiter, bevor die anderen überhaupt begriffen haben, dass Web gab.
Ach so, dann hat man endlich mal einen Grund, das für iMovie anzuschmeißen, in der Garage Band.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, womit machst du das eigentlich? Also womit nimmst du auf, womit schneidest du?
Gutes Thema. Was braucht man eigentlich?
Man braucht nicht viel.
Was für ein Mikrofon hast du?
Tatsächlich gibt es einige Podcasts, die ich gemacht habe mit dem eingebauten Mini-Mikrofon meines Powerbooks. Also ich habe zum Beispiel zwei Podcasts live aus dem ICE gemacht. Als ich dann morgens um 6 im Zug saß, irgendwie schön in dieses kleine Mikro reingesprungen. Das sord dann so ein bisschen im Hintergrund.
Ich war aber gar nicht so schlecht. Ich habe mich immer gewundert, ob du da noch ein Mikro dabei hast.
Die Daten noch im Kopf kann man ja mal reinhören.
Würde ich einfach mal auf spreeblick.com gehen und dann im Suchfeld nach ICE suchen. Und dann kommen da auch die Podcasts. Da muss man immer noch mal auf den Titel klicken. Und dann kann man die suchen halt so ein bisschen. Aber das ist ja auch auch was Schönes. Irgendwie ist ja diese ganze Weblog- und Podcastszene, die hat ja auch immer noch so ein Punk-Rock-Charakter, finde ich. Ja, weil es geht einfach darum, es ist wichtiger, was du da machst, als ob das technisch perfekt ist oder so. Es geht darum, drei Akkorde zu können, und wenn du die drauf hast, und dann noch in der richtigen Reihenfolge, immer in der richtigen Geschwindigkeit und in den richtigen Worten bringst...
Entschuldigung, aber genau der Meinung bin ich nicht, dass es schlecht klingen darf.
Ich meine, das darf nicht schlecht klingen, aber es ist nicht so wichtig. Also irgendjemand hatte mal gemailt, die Qualität und jetzt 96 Kilobit pro Sekunde und so. I don't fucking care. Also es muss gut klingen, natürlich. Es muss hörbar sein, es soll dich nicht nerven. Der Inhalt soll nicht von der Technik nach hinten gedrückt werden, weil sie so schlecht ist. Aber ansonsten geht mir das ganze Technik-Geseiere total auf den Wecker.
Womit nimmst du denn auf?
Also du kannst, man braucht... Außer dem Computer und dem, wenn möglich, eingebauten Mikrofon bei einem Laptop oder so, dann geht das auch. Es gibt kostenlose Audioprogramme überall, Freeware. Bei Mac ist Garageband bei den neueren mit drin. Damit geht das wunderbar. Da kann man sogar noch einen Kompressor einsetzen und keine Ahnung, und Peak Limit und weiß ich nicht. Da spielt man ein bisschen mit rum. Da kann man auch schneiden und so weiter. Das Ding dann nach iTunes exportieren und dann auch noch einen MP3 draus machen. Also da muss man sich ein bisschen einlesen, aber es dauert einen halben Tag, mal ein bisschen was im Internet lesen und ausprobieren, dann geht das. Benutzst du einen Mischpunkt? Ja, wenn es ein bisschen besser klingen soll, wenn es in der Ecke besser klingen soll, dann kann man darüber nachdenken, dass man sich ein externes Mischpult besorgt. Ich habe eins gekauft für 80 Euro neu. Das ist so ein kleines...
Ein Zwei-Kanal-Mischer oder was?
Nee, der hat sogar vier oder sechs Kanäle. Gibt es inzwischen richtig günstig. Ich weiß die Firma nicht mal. Ich bin in so ein Musikinstrumentes Shop reingegangen, habe gesagt, ich will einen Mischpult unter 100 Euro und er hat gesagt, hier, das kostet 80. Und das ist super, das Ding. Und ein Mikro habe ich noch, ein relativ gutes von Shure, das ein guter Mikrofonhersteller ist, habe ich noch aus alten Bandtagen mit rübergeschleppt. Das kommt dann in den Line-In vom Computer und dann klingt das mit Garage Band alles prima.
Was heißt mit Garage Band? Was machst du dann konkret mit der Audiodatei, außer sie in MP3 zu wandeln?
Ich habe ja noch einen Musikrätsel täglich. Da wird dann auch noch aus iTunes mal ein Song ausgesucht und exportiert, in Garage Band reingepackt, geschnitten, irgendwie so einen Schnipsel rausgenommen. Meistens ist das ja der Anfang. Das geht da auch total fix. Dann schneidest du natürlich oder, wenn du merkst, dir geht gerade die Puste aus oder dir fehlt das Thema, dann machst du Pause bei der Aufnahme und fängst wieder von vorne an und so eine Geschichte.
Machst du noch so irgendwie Audio-Kompressionen oder so?
Das mache ich auch noch. Wenn du so weit in die Technik gehen wollt, was bei der Stimme schon ganz praktisch ist, wenn man im Audioprogramm irgendwo die Möglichkeit hat, einen Kompressor einzusetzen. Ein Kompressor macht im Grunde genommen das, was ihr jetzt hört, was ihr eben nicht hört, sondern er sorgt dafür, dass wenn ich leise rede, dass ihr mich genauso gut hört, wie wenn ich plötzlich lauter werde. Der Kompressor passt das so ein bisschen an, ohne dabei undynamisch zu werden. Also er macht nicht einfach, wenn ich leise rede, lauter, und wenn ich laut rede, leiser, sondern er macht das sehr dynamisch, sodass halt...
Mit einem richtig guten Niesanfall kann man den übrigens aushebeln. Also da kommt er dann nicht mehr mit, da flippen dann die Satellitenhörer komplett aus.
Tatsache.
Weil die kriegen den sowieso nicht ab.
Aber das ist tatsächlich, da muss man auch damit vorsichtig sein. Manchmal hört man es nicht so richtig, man sollte sich, wenn man sich dafür dann interessiert, sollte man sich auch so ein bisschen die kleinen, die Kurven angucken, die man da plötzlich auf dem Monitor hat, wenn man Ton plötzlich sehen kann.
Und ein bisschen Mikrofondisziplin, das reicht ja schon.
Ja, man ist schon ins Mikro reden. Oder was vielleicht ein guter Tipp für wirklich Anfänger ist, eben nicht direkt ins Mikro reden. Lieber ein bisschen höher auspegeln und dran vorbei reden. Weil sonst hat man nämlich, wenn man keinen Pop-Schutz hat und so weiter, dann geht das bei diesem hervorragenden Mikrofondier nicht. Dann machst du nämlich nicht mehr... Weil ich das daneben mache, ist es nicht mehr so schlimm.
Nicht ganz so schlimm, ja. Ich habe es mittlerweile runtergeladen. Wir können mal reinhören in den Spreblik-Podcast, aufgenommen mit einem internen Mikrofon.
Die Tageszeitungen sind heute voll mit Bildern von Saramkusein und...
Das klingt wie die Verkehrsdurchsagen im privaten Radio, die immer so tun, als hätten sie Flugzeuge, aus denen sie überwiesen werden.
Aber du hast schon das Kinn auf der Tastatur da, oder? Ich wundere mich, dass man sonst niemand aus dem ACI hört.
Erste Klasse. Welchen hast du denn untergeladen, den letzten?
Den erstbesten.
Den erstbesten, dann musst du mal ganz ans Ende gehen, weil dann hörst du Leute.
Dann kannst du den zweitbesten.
Kannst du dir mal ein bisschen vorspulen. Geh mal zum Schluss, wenn die Kurve ein bisschen runter geht. Weiter, weiter. Stopp, geh mal da irgendwo rein.
Das ist ja mitten aus dem Leben.
Der Punkt ist, es war deswegen vorher so leise, weil ich vom Ausbauhof gefahren bin und bis zu Bank 2 ist es da oft recht leer. Und dann versuche ich halt, also ich habe es jetzt das zweite Mal gemacht, und das ist natürlich schon klasse, wenn du da sitzt und dann hängst du so ein bisschen blöd über deinem Powerbook und guckst so ein bisschen, guckt irgendjemand, und dann ist es so ein bisschen peinlich.
Im London ist dafür einer erschossen worden.
Und dreh das halt so ein bisschen blöd in dein Powerbook rein. Aber Bahnhof Zoo steigen dann natürlich viele Leute ein.
Dann ist es laut.
Dann muss es fertig sein.
Was machen Sie denn da? Ja, ich kaste Pott.
Genau.
Da würde ja niemand jemand fragen, was machen Sie denn da? Das ist ja der Witz immer, man muss einfach nur frech sein, wobei ich war noch nie, also auch früher als...
Warst du denn im Großraumabteil oder im...
Im Großraum, ja. Aber ich war noch nie so richtig der Reporter. Ich hab's immer gehasst, auch auf der Straße Leute anzusprechen.
Kann ich auch nicht.
Das war nie meiner... Deswegen... Aber es gibt Leute, die lieben das und die können sich auch in ICE setzen und einfach da in den Laptop reinquatschen, dass es funktioniert. Da sagt keiner, was machen sie da?
Chaosradio 107 und Podcasting, unser Thema und den Überblick gibt's, Überblick Teil 2 gibt's von Tim.
Den, ja, der Audio-Blogosphäre sozusagen. Ja, es gibt, also ich muss sagen, ich war wirklich begeistert. Also ich hab, bin schwer reingefallen, gerade über dieses Wochenende, das ganze Thema und hab irgendwie den iPod nicht mehr von den Ohren bekommen. Das endete dann so, dass ich morgens aufgewacht bin und es liefen immer noch irgendwelche Podcasts auf meinem Ohr, irgendwie nur noch die Kopfhörer auf und ich irgendwie einfach weggedöst bin dabei. Nicht weil es langweilig war, aber weil ich dann halt irgendwann auch einfach zu müde war, um noch weiter zuzuhören. Aber dabei sind schöne Sachen auch gefallen. Und du hast mich ja vorhin gefragt, wo habe ich denn das eigentlich alles her? So ja, also nicht nur wie findest du das jetzt in diesem und jenen Verzeichnissen? Ich hab dir nicht die ganzen Verzeichnisse abgeklappert, sondern ich hab vor allem mehr Podcasts angehört und eben gehört, worüber die reden, genauso wie man eben auch Weblogs findet. Man findet Weblogs eben dadurch, dass man Weblogs liest und den Verweisen folgt. Und so ähnlich funktioniert das eben auch jetzt schon bei dem Podcasting. Die Leute schicken ja auch Audio-Kommentare ein, also mp3-Schnipsel per E-Mail oder wie auch immer, die dann wiederum gespielt werden und wodurch sich eben so eine Diskussion entwickelte. Adam Curry macht das in seiner Show recht aktiv und fordert die Leute auch jedes Mal wieder auf, zum bestimmten Thema dann Stellung zu nehmen, was sie dann auch in der Regel tun. Und das macht die Sendung auch sehr lebendig, weil man auch immer wieder andere Stimmen hört. Und ich denke, das ist eine besondere Kraft, immer diese, ja, direkt an die Quelle zu kommen, an diese Stimmenquelle.
Was wir gerade machen, ist, dass wir Kommentare per Telefon zulassen. Also du kriegst eine Berliner Nummer und kannst halt den Podcast hören. Und wenn du dazu was zu sagen hast, so wie in einem Blog-Eintrag, kannst du eine ganz normale Festnetznummer anrufen, kannst da 30 Sekunden raufquatschen und das Ding geht dann automatisch in den Kommentaren als Soundfile online.
Ah, das ist natürlich schick.
Achso, mit dem 343M System, haben wir ja auch hier alle schon benutzt. Das ist auch eine Sache, die man durchaus erwähnen sollte. 343M.projekt-brot.de Genau, das ist so ein absurdes Experiment, mehr kann man das nicht nennen.
Naja, das ist. Gemein.
Nein, nicht so gemein, nicht so fies, bis einer weint.
Ich habe daran teilgenommen und meine Teilnahme war ein absurdes Experiment. Also das war es bei Holger auch nicht anders.
Genau, das sind nämlich dann die Kommentare, die wir hinterlassen haben.
Ich könnte dann auch noch ein paar bekloppte Live-Reiseberichte aus dem Flugzeug finden.
Nein, Max ist einer der ersten, der Mob-Gecastet hat.
Ich versuche gerade das Wort zu erfinden.
Mobcast.
Der halt irgendwie mit dem Telefon unterwegs war und seine kurzen Podcasts.
Mobcast, das ist ja Audio.
Ja, das ist total großartig.
Ich finde das super, aber ein absurdes Experiment war ja auch eher positiv. Man konnte sich einfach mal austoben. Man nimmt einfach das Telefon in dem Moment, wo einem danach ist und lässt einfach mal was ab. Das ist kein großes Recording, man muss da irgendwie kein Mikrofon in der Hand halten, man plappert halt einfach ins Handy rein und fertig ist die Laube. Ja, das ist eine super Idee übrigens mit den Audio-Kommentaren per Telefon. Das ist die Spitze. Also das müsste man halt sehen, schneidest du das dann und dann schneidest du es vielleicht auch, sozusagen noch mal die Best of the Best mit rein.
Genau, die müssen dann immer noch rüber. Das funktioniert aber auch relativ simpel, man...
Das heißt, ich RSS'e dann auch die Audio-Kommentare und verliere mich dann komplett im Spreeblick, weil ich mir erst deine 7, 5 Minuten Podcast anhöre und danach 3 Stunden Audio-Kommentare für irgendwie nennen.
Das heißt, es gibt doch noch ein Feed mit den Kommentaren, auch noch als Podcast.
Naja, der Feed ist, also ich bin froh, wenn jetzt mal die Audio-Kommentar funktionieren läuft, denn Feed ist, der ist glaube ich, das kleinste Problem dabei.
Das ist, sag ich mal jetzt so, Max.
Nein, aber ich glaube, dass es tatsächlich technisch nicht so ein Problem ist. Es ist immer alles eine Zeitfrage. Man darf ja wirklich dabei nicht vergessen und das frage ich mich halt schon bei vielen Leuten. Also Thomas Warnhoff, mit dem hatte ich ja auch mal über Zeit geredet und er sagte, ach das ist gar nicht so viel Zeit und so. Aber ich frage mich schon, wie der ganze Kram funktionieren soll. Aber wenn du ein bisschen Qualitätsanspruch an Inhalt und Technik auch hast, dann sitzt du einfach eine Weile. Und ich könnte es alleine zum Beispiel nicht. Also ich könnte mich natürlich einfuchsen, dann sitze ich drei, vier Tage daran, den Kram zum Laufen zu bringen. Wenn Max hilft oder wenn Max es macht, dauert es vielleicht einen Tag, was immer noch lang genug ist. Also es ist auch ein Tag, wenn jemand die richtige Ahnung hat und ansonsten hoch bezahlt ist.
Ja, irgendjemand muss ja experimentieren.
Ja natürlich, tun wir ja auch gerne, aber manchmal dauert es dann halt ein bisschen länger. Aber das ist ja auch keiner böse. Und was wollte ich sagen, genau, wenn wir das am Laufen haben, dann kannst du natürlich irgendwann, kannst du dich darin verrennen.
Chaosradio 107, unser Thema ist heute der Spereweg.
Und weiter mit Chaosradio 107, der Sendung mittels Sprengling.
Noch nicht.
Ist wieder Semesterschwester?
Uni Fritz.
Die Uni im Radio. Von A wie Audimax bis Z wie 20-Semester Publizistik. Das Radio an der Uni. Auf der großen Fritz-Unit-Tour an 6 Universitäten in Berlin und Brandenburg. Und zum Abschluss die große Uni Fritz Disco. Freitag, 4. November, 23 Uhr, Fritz Club in Postbahnhof. Direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof. Uni Fritz Disco. Du bist Student? Du hast einen Studentenausweis? Du kommst umsonst auf die Party.
Im Club, an der Uni und im Radio.
Info.
Mach ich.
Was war das denn?
Das war, ich weiß auch nicht, ich glaube, das war Johnny. Nachrichten mit Matthias Kerkhoff. Viele haben mir vorbeigekommen und es ist gemerkt, aber gut. Nachrichten mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Bundestag und NATO haben die Bundeswehr im 50.Jahresbestehens als Grundpfeiler der internationalen Sicherheitspolitik gewürdigt. Erstmals in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik marschierten am Abend Soldaten zu einem großen Zapfenstreich vor den Reichstagsgebäude auf. Rund 2000 Sicherheitskräfte schützten das Zeremoniell mit rund 5000 Gästen. Union und SPD wollen die Kronzeugenregelung wieder einführen. Außerdem haben Union und SPD gestern die Eckpunkte für Sparmaßnahmen im Bundeshaushalt festgelegt. Die Staats- und Regierungschefs der 25 EU-Staaten befassen sich heute mit der wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Zukunft Europas. Bei dem Treffen nahe London steht die Globalisierung im Mittelpunkt. Die internationale Gemeinschaft in Pakistan hat zusätzliche Kötastrophenhilfe zugesagt. Die UNO teilte mit, dass die Staaten zusätzlich 525 Millionen Dollar bereitstellen wollen. Fußball hatte BSC steht im Achtelfinale des DFB-Pokals. Die Berliner besiegten am Abend München-Gladbach mit 3 zu 0. Ausgeschieden ist dagegen Energie Cottbus. Der Zweitligist unterlag bei Arminia Bielefeld 1 zu 2. Titelverteidiger Bayern München gewann bei Erzgebirge Auer 1 zu 0. Stuttgart und Duisburg scheiterten dagegen an ihren Zweitligagegnern. Stuttgart verloren Rostock 2 zu 3. Duisburg unterlag 1860 München mit dem gleichen Ergebnis. Und noch Basketball am fünften Spieltag. In der Basketball-Liga gewann Alper Berlin in Karlsruhe 98 zu 67. Nachts ist trocken bei 6 bis 10 Grad am Tag. Dann bewölkt später etwas freundlicher. Es bleibt trocken bei 16 bis 19 Grad. Berlin, Treptow, Köpenick, Adler gestellt. Zwischen der Kreuzung Richterstraße und Fetschauer liehen beiden Richtungen noch immer Gefahr durch mehrere Wildschweinrotten auf der Fahrbahn. Bitte Vorsicht, die Tiere haben keine Ortskenntnisse.
Vielen Dank, Matthias Gerkhoff, 5 nach halb 1.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6, dann Fritz in Berlin.
Du hast es kaputt gemacht. Du hast es kaputt gemacht.
Nein, ich hab's gar nicht kaputt gemacht.
Du hast es kaputt gemacht. You broke the bloody ship.
Da ist es wieder.
Chaosradio 107 habt ihr eingeschaltet. Ein paar Minuten haben wir noch, um über Podcasting zu sprechen. Podcasting, das automatisierte MP3 runterladen. Ja, im Wesentlichen.
Im Wesentlichen und im Besonderen, aber nicht unbedingt ausschließlich, sondern es gibt halt auch, wie schon erwähnt, auch Video. Es gibt auch auch PDF-Quellen. Also mir ist zwar jetzt noch kein...
PDF-Quellen?
Ja, weil dieser...
Da bräuchte man nur einen fünftigen E-Book-Reader, ne?
Naja, einfach einen PDF-Reader. Reicht ja vollkommen aus. Ja, naja gut. Ich denke nicht, dass das so eine Killer-Applikation ist, jetzt die ganze Zeit mobil PDFs zu lesen. Also bis das irgendwie das Buch ersetzt, glaube ich, da muss noch einiges erfunden werden. Aber trotzdem ist es ganz interessant, weil man halt in seine Podcastshows eben auch mal eben Hintergrundmaterial reinwerfen kann, indem man eben auch einfach einen Link auf einem PDF einfach mit in diesen Feed mit reingibt. Und so wie das MP3 oder eben das Filmchen auftaucht, so kann eben dann auch eine PDF-Datei auftauchen, die klickt man ein bisschen und dann sind da eben Informationen aller Art mit Links und so weiter. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen Hypertext. Das ist schon ganz, ja, ich finde das gut. Also das macht einfach diesen Media-Mix noch sehr viel interessanter. Und man hat eben eine ganze Menge Gestaltungsfreiraum, um eben seinen Blog einfach auch sehr interessant zu machen. Technisch sind alle Voraussetzungen gegeben. Jetzt muss man halt gucken, wie man das macht.
Gibt es eigentlich schon so einen Kiffer Podcast?
Ja, die versuchen es seit ein paar Wochen.
Also bei kiffer.de gibt es auf jeden Fall auch Radio und ich glaube, von Podcasten, die liegen mir so richtig weit entfernt.
Das fände ich aber auch mal irgendwie nicht schlecht. Also nur dann zu Podcasten, wenn man breit, blau oder drauf ist. Und trunken und genau als Podcast.
Lass mich noch mal auf ein paar interessante Sachen verweisen.
Bist du denn so ernst drauf heute?
Ich finde, diese ganze Albernheit reicht jetzt auch.
Bist du schon albern?
Ich bin ja hier nicht beim Chaosradio.
Ich bin ja hier angefangen, albern zu sein, mein Lieber.
Sei mal nicht so ernst, wir sind hier nicht bei Arte, Freundchen.
Gott sei Dank kann ich auch auf die Qualität verzichten.
Ja, sei froh, sonst würde ich ja eh nicht von dem Mic-Glock hier sitzen. Wer nächster was sagt, hat gewonnen.
Tim wollte noch ein paar Tipps geben.
Ja, ich wollte noch ein paar Tipps geben. Es gibt einfach noch ein paar schöne Sachen, die auch gerade ganz gut bekannt werden. Gerade in diesem Video-Podcasting-Bereich zwei gute Tipps, wie ich finde, wenn man ein bisschen Spaß haben will, ist Rocketboom. Das ist so eine tägliche News aus dem Internet, also News in Anführungsstrichen, Sendung mit der charmanten Amanda. Die sitzt dann immer schön frontal und berichtet so was im Web gerade.
Full Frontal Nudity?
Ja, sie ist ganz lustig drauf und berichtet auch immer so schön direkt von dem Neuigkeiten-Tisch des Internets, bringt immer lustige Videos mit rein. Das muss man sich einfach mal anschauen. Rocketboom, das ist ganz einfach zu finden, ich glaube dort kommt. Und der totale Knaller gerade ist Tiki Bar TV. Das finde ich wirklich super. Es sind bisher 9 Episoden rausgekommen. Es sind immer so 5-6 Minuten lange einzelne lustige Episoden mit so 3 Leuten. Dr. Tiki, Lala und ich glaube Johnny heißt derjenige, der mit den Cocktails merkt, es geht immer um Cocktails an der Bar. Darum herum schaffen sie immer schöne lustige Geschichten. Das ist sehr sehenswert und sehr lustig. Und im seriösen Bereich gibt es natürlich auch noch einiges, auf das man verweisen muss. Und an der Stelle wird Podcasting auch mal wieder jetzt seinem Anspruch gerecht. Eine alternative Information, Democracy Now, so eine sehr engagierte politische tägliche Fernsehsendung von, wie heißt sie noch gleich? Amy? Ich kriege es durcheinander gerade. Aber Democracy Now ist auch bei iTunes auch überall zu finden. Die haben halt einen Tag Real-World-News sozusagen, die Nachrichten, die man sonst nirgends sieht. Eine 1-Stunden Fernsehsendung, auch als Podcast empfangbar. Das ist auf jeden Fall interessant, um mal so ein bisschen auch hinter die Kulissen zu schauen. Das deckt in den USA sicherlich einen Nachrichtenbedarf ab, den man so auf den normalen Fernsehwellen nicht mehr findet. Das wird sehr interessant, was dabei rauskommt. Aber die Technik taucht auch noch für andere Sachen, zum Beispiel auch für Unterricht, habe ich gemerkt. Also das könnte auch sehr interessant sein für Universitäten. Aufzeichnungen von Vorträgen zu machen, zum Beispiel und die eben auch per Podcasting zu verbreiten. Man kann ja auch mit dieser Technik Bilder in diesen Enhanced Podcast mit reinzutun, also Bookmarks zu setzen, kann man zum Beispiel wunderbar Vorträge mit Slides direkt in einer Audiodatei delivern.
Das finde ich extrem spannend, ja.
Das geht echt gut und man sieht halt einfach die Slides an sich vorbei wandern und hat eben dazu Ton. Das Ganze eben in einer einzigen Datei, also da muss gar nicht sehr viel drum herum gemacht werden. Es funktioniert jetzt schon so auf einem, ja auch auf einem iPod, aber eben auch in iTunes oder welches Programm auch immer dieses Format dann noch unterstützen wird.
Und eine andere Geschichte, die man mit Podcasts auch großartig machen kann, sind so Guides, also so, ich wollte jetzt nicht Führer sagen, zum Beispiel so ein Städteführer, also das ist auch so. Ich suche tatsächlich noch einen bezahlbaren, mobilen, hochqualitativ hochwertigen Recorder, weil das wäre zum Beispiel auch eine schöne Idee, dass du einfach deine Straße, keine Ahnung, du läufst durch die Straße und sagst, so jetzt stehe ich hier und weiß nicht, dass das und das passiert, oder hat der und der mal gewohnt, jetzt gehen wir mal langsam weiter und da vorne an der Telefonzelle bleiben wir mal stehen und drehen uns rechts um. Das denkt jetzt auf dem iPod von irgendjemand anders, der sich das anhört und dann durch die Straße geht. Museen setzen ja MP3 auch schon ein.
Aber was für ein Recorder brauchst du dafür? Ich meine, du brauchst doch...
Ne, du brauchst schon, das muss schon anstrengend klingen, wenn du da auf der Straße stehst und aufnimmst. Das muss schon ein bisschen besser sein.
Achso, gut, ich dachte jetzt, der irgendwie Video mit aufnimmt oder so, weil das wäre ja eigentlich hilfreich, das kannst du dann hinterher mischen.
Mit Video kannst du natürlich auch prima machen, aber einfach nur jemand, der sich die Kopfhörer aufsetzt und so wie es Museen auch machen, als Führung durch irgendeine Ausstellung, kannst du natürlich alternative Städteführer damit auch entwickeln, was auch schon gemacht wird.
Ein vernünftiges Kehlkopf-Mikrofon ist eigentlich das, was du brauchst dafür, ne?
Ja, und den Recorder.
Kehlkopf-Mikrofon.
Na gut, das kannst du auch mit MD machen im Zweifelsfall.
Es geht ja schon so ein bisschen um Speed bei der ganzen Geschichte und wenn du dann mit einem MD-Player-Recorder unterwegs bist, dann musst du das Zeug wieder rüberspielen und keine Ahnung.
Wir wollten das Drogenthema raushalten aus der Sendung.
Ach, das ist aber die ganz hässliche Droge. Klappe-Pen-Schwester.
Ich hab noch ein paar Basswörter hier auf meiner Liste.
Oh, endlich.
Ja, zum Beispiel Screencasting.
Wadat, das ist, es gab ja schon längere Zeit Tools, mit denen man die Aktivitäten auf dem eigenen Bildschirm, wenn man mit dem Computer arbeitet, in einen Movie packt. So, das Ganze mit Podcasting.
The Scene produziert damit, ne? Das ist es doch, oder nicht?
Das mag sein, dass die sowas auch benutzen und das dann noch zusammen mischen.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar, aber was Tim erwähnt hat?
Screencasting.
Was heißt denn?
Screencasting, also...
Was war nochmal gleich Screencasting?
Also das heißt, der Videocontent, den man sieht, ist nichts anderes als eine aufgezeichnete Session am Rechner. Das Ganze dann eben aber mit Ton. Und das wird eben benutzt für Demos, für Tutorials. Ich erkläre Leuten, wie sie sich ihren E-Mail-Account an der Uni einrichten. Da habe ich was ganz Pfiffiges gesehen, wo jemand sich auch noch selber mit der Kamera gefilmt hat, das Bild auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt hat und dann eben dazu erklärt hat, wie man E-Mail-Account mit dem und dem Programm einrichtet. Aber nicht nur irgendeine komische Instruktionswebseite, sondern einfach ein Filmchen zum Angucken, wo man genau sieht, hier musst du das eintragen, hier musst du das eintragen, hier musst du das eintragen. Es gibt jetzt schon Tutorials für Photoshop und andere Programme, wo einfach bestimmte Techniken erläutert werden, die eben auch als Videopodcast rausgehen. Und da, glaube ich, ist auch noch eine ganze Menge Potenzial. Was ich auch super fand, sind Podcasts, die einem Sprachen beibringen. Da würde ich auch ganz gerne mal kurz was anspielen, vielleicht, dass man mal so einen Eindruck bekommt. Mache ich mal kurz die Musik aus, machst mich vielleicht mal ein bisschen lauter. Das ist der English as a Second Language Podcast aus Kalifornien, der erklärt das sehr. Also er fängt halt hier erstmal an, sich vorzustellen.
Er redet auch immer sehr schön langsam.
Im nächsten Album hören wir uns genau das an.
Untergarantie. Ja, und dann erzählt er erstmal so eine Geschichte am Anfang. So typisch, wie das eben mit Sprache ist. So, was ich heute so erlebe. Heute hat er irgendwie Car-Trouble, kommt ein bisschen Musik und jetzt fängt er erstmal an, einfach nur die Geschichte zu erzählen.
Ich kenne einen Typen, der macht daraus Musik.
Kein Computer, der spricht so. Ich spure jetzt mal ein bisschen vor, so ein paar Minuten später kommt dann halt nochmal Musik. Ich habe gesagt, dass es nicht gut.
So mache ich jetzt alle meine Podcasts.
Ich denke, wenn wir Chaosradio auf diese Weite bringen, müssen wir die Sendung auf sechs Stunden verlängern.
Das impliziert jedoch.
Ich glaube, wir müssen das gleich wieder bleiben lassen.
Wir haben nur noch ein paar Minuten.
Aber es hat überhaupt niemand angerufen, der selber podcastt?
Nein, aus irgendeinem unerfindlichen Grund nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist die Telefonanlage kaputt oder so.
Ich glaube, die sind alles solche Frühaufsteher, die sind jetzt alle schon im Bett.
Ja, fand ich auch verblüffend.
Hat man bei Thomas gesehen. Noch nicht so verbreitet. 11 Uhr, da kippen die um.
Da kippen die ab. Die Podcaster, Schwächlinge.
Memmen, Pfeifen, Luschen.
Memmen, ich sitze nachts stundenlang und...
Und Podcaste. Podcaste für die Schublade.
Und die sind nicht mal in der Lage.
Ich bin bis nachts unterwegs und morgens schon wieder raus.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal so ein bisschen unsere Lieblingspodcast hier erwähnen. Also, Johnnie, du hast gesagt, du hörst gar nichts.
Ich höre in ganz viele Sachen rein. Aber es gibt nichts, was ich abonniert habe und jeden Tag höre. So, so. Nichts. Und zwar wirklich, also auch was du zum Beispiel, ich habe mir viele von den V-Logs angeguckt und, oder sagt man Vlog, das kleine Beschreibung.
Man sagt erst mal noch überhaupt nichts.
Okay, also von den Videocasts. Zum Beispiel dieses Tiki-Ding, da irgendwie diese Cocktailgeschichte und so. Ja, das ist schon ganz hübsch, wenn man da mal reinguckt. Aber muss ich das regelmäßig sehen? Antwort nein.
Da musst du gar nichts.
Nein, aber ich meine...
Du musst doch nicht regelmäßig Blogs lesen.
Das Interessante ist, man verpasst ja nicht mal was. Ich hab hier anderthalb Wochen war ich ja zwangs offline, weil ich krank im Gästezimmer meiner Eltern lag. Und da ist Internet, ist da nicht. So komisches Zeug, so neumatisches, das haben die nicht. Die haben einen VHS-Videorekorder und der zeigt auch die falsche Uhrzeit an.
Kein Internet?
Und dann hab ich gedacht, ach ja, mein Gott, jetzt hast du hier kein Internet. Und hab hinterher festgestellt, als ich nach Hause kam, hat mein RSS-Reader angezeigt. 1800! Und ich hatte nichts verpasst? Null, gar nichts.
Großes Problem für mich. Wobei das mit dem Fernsehen ja eigentlich ähnlich ist, wenn wir ehrlich sind.
Ja, das ist eher wahrscheinlich mit allen Medien.
Ja, ich finde Tageszeitung viel schon noch meine andere Geschichte.
Radio ist wichtig.
Ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass nicht öffentlich-rechtlich ist Radio.
Natürlich, auch schließlich. Ja, auch.
Richtig, ihr hört Radio?
Ich höre den ganzen Tag Radio, ja.
Den ganzen Tag nicht, aber ich höre schon in der Morgenzeit.
Den ganzen Tag, bei mir läuft den ganzen Tag das Radio.
Ich mach's aber nicht.
Selbst wenn der Fernseher an ist.
Dein Radio läuft? Ja, super.
Das ist aus intelligentem Birnbaumholz.
Ich mach sowas nicht. Ich höre keinen Radio.
Übrigens, mein Powerbook, 12 Zoll und eineinhalb Jahre alt, hat immer noch 32 Prozent Batterie. Das ist an, seit 21.30 Uhr. Wollte ich nur mal sagen.
Respekt.
Um jetzt vielleicht in den letzten acht Minuten noch die Windows-Mac-Diskussion loszutun.
Da kann ich ja gleich gegenhalten.
Wir haben ganz viele Leute. Wieso willst du denn deine Diskussion losdrehen? Windows ist Mist.
Leute, macht mir nicht fertig.
Ja, dann mach doch mal Musik an.
Nein. Nicht? Doch. Ja, mach ich. Da. Das beruhigt euch wieder, ne?
Jetzt lenken sie sich endlich wieder hin.
Das ist so Homer Simpson.
Also ich wollte noch mal was zu sagen. Was hört man denn überhaupt regelmäßig? Wo ist jetzt irgendwie das Mithörpotenzial? Ich meine, das Leute das tun, das merkst du ja nun an deinem eigenen Blog. Bis jetzt. Angelebe Stimme, immer wieder interessante Ideen. Danke schön. Bitte schön. Du könntest aber auch noch mal ein bisschen mit Interviews spielen und als persönliches Feedback gestehen.
Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Bis jetzt. Das ist alles machbar und da wird's dann übrigens auch wieder spannend mit dem Streamen und Live-Senden und keine Ahnung. Man kann ja über Skype zum Beispiel auch senden.
Senden?
In viele oder was?
Ach so, du meinst jetzt als Telefoncall-In?
Was?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich dich richtig verstanden habe.
Also über Skype kann man die Leute gut anrufen. Als Telefonkonferenz.
Für eine Live-Sendung.
Du kannst ja auch live was senden über Skype zum Beispiel.
Wohin?
An irgendjemand.
Also an eine Person.
Na ja, du kannst ja Skype auch anrufen. Vom Konzert oder so.
Jetzt Johnny, komm. Du hörst auch noch keine Podcasts?
Nein, wie gesagt, bei mir läuft tatsächlich den ganzen Tag das Radio. Und das Einzige, was ich dann tatsächlich als Podcast höre, das sind die Sachen im Deutschlandfunk oder Deutschlandradio, die ich verpasst habe.
Bis jetzt.
RSS, das hab ich noch gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Ja, also nicht alles was geschrieben ist, gibt es auch in Audio, aber alles was Audio ist, gibt es auch geschrieben. Und es ist, soweit ich das jetzt erinnere, eins zu eins der Texte, wie er im Web steht, vorgelesen, aber es klingt nicht vorgelesen, sondern ist einfach sehr schön vorgetragen. Gerade jetzt der letzte Podcast, den ich noch gehört hab auf dem Weg hier ins Studio.
Ich soll Multicasting sagen.
Multicasting?
Ja, es gab, keiner kann senden, mehrere können hören, Konferenz Multicasting.
Kannst du sagen, ein Closed Circuit Live-Bootleg von Konzerten?
Wow. Auf jeden Fall würde ich dir das ans Herz legen, Holger.
Absolut, ich hab's ja sowieso als Text schon abonniert.
Das ist eine schöne Sache. Und ich bin mir ganz sicher, es wird noch eine ganze Menge andere Blüten treiben, weil in Deutschland geht es jetzt eigentlich erst so richtig los. Das ist genauso wie mit den Webblogs, das brauchste seine Zeit. Und ich denke, wir werden auch noch eine ganze Menge nette Experimente erleben. Ein Experiment, was nicht so direkt mit Podcasting zu tun hat, aber schon auch irgendwie. Müssen wir noch, dürfen wir nicht unerwähnt lassen, hast du da gerade nochmal die Ohrl im Kopf, wie hießen die Jungs? Nicht Performance Theater, sondern...
Ach so, diese, diese...
Genau, das MP3 Experiment. Wissen wir gleich, auf jeden Fall, was haben die gemacht? Die haben eine Performance angekündigt im Web. Das ging im Prinzip so. Hallo liebe Leute, bitte findet euch alle im Park ein, war das im Central Park in New York? Im Central Park in New York, am Datum Uhrzeit. Und bitte ladet euch dieses MP3 runter, auf euern portablen Musikabspielgerät und hört es euch nicht an. Bis jetzt.
Flashmob 2.0 ist es.
Genau, Flashmob 2.0, schönes, ja schöner Vergleich. Und alle liefen also voll synchronisiert durch diese MP3-Datei im Ohr, durch die Gegend, wie Zombies und haben andere lustige Sachen gemacht, dann kamen auf einmal vier verkleidete Typen, irgendwie die Biene, der Delfin, der See-Captain und wer war noch gleich der vierte?
Ah, vergess ich immer.
Dann haben nämlich tatsächlich alle Leute sich auch noch vier verschiedene MP3-Dateien runtergeladen und dann unterschiedliche Dinge getan. Einer sind dem Seebären hinterhergelaufen, der andere irgendwie mit dem Delfin. Total großartig lustige Aktionen. Haben die schon das zweite gemacht?
Flashmobs, Radioballets sind so Stichworte, nach denen man da aussuchen kann. Das gibt es auch in Deutschland natürlich, solche Geschichten. Aber nicht so Improve Everywhere heißen die. Und ich könnte jetzt die Spreblik-Ul sagen, aber dann sagt ihr wieder, ich muss extra zahlen.
Ja, wie dem auch sei, ihr guckt einfach mal in den nächsten 24 Stunden auf Spreblik.de, da wird Johnny dann den ein oder anderen Link hingeschrieben haben und damit wird die Blockpause.
Der macht gerade Blockpause.
Ach, der soll sich mal nicht so haben.
Ich werde das in den Chaosradio Podcast reinwerfen.
Oder in den Chaosradio Podcast reinwerfen.
Und da könnt ihr mal alle klicken.
Das war Chaosradio 107. Es ging um Podcasting, das habt ihr gerade vielleicht noch gehört. Im Studio war Johnny Häusler, Spreblik.de, Tim Pridloff, ccc.de. Die Knöpfchen hat gedrückt, Holger Klein, Stacken Blochen. Es geht hier gleich weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf und Chaosradio 108. Hört ihr am Mittwoch, dem 30. November 2005, haben wir schon ein Thema, Tim?
108 Sendungen.
Fürs nächste Chaosradio gibt es noch kein offizielles Thema, das ist noch geheim.
Das ist was.
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Sachen, Tim.
Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit.